Moin Leute, okay, jetzt muss ich meine Fake-E-Mail-Adresse anzeigen, meine Fake-Account, kapalul.com, da scheint es zu funktionieren.
Ich muss nochmal kurz meine Stream-Vorschau anmachen auf dem zweiten Rechner, sonst sehe ich nämlich nichts gescheit, außer jetzt hier gerade den Chat im Fullscreen.
Ja, ich bin gerade reingekommen vor 10 Minuten, ja, ungefähr, aber ich bin heute nicht die ganz große Runde gelaufen, es war echt ein bisschen kalt und irgendwie war es heute auch ein bisschen anstrengend, also insofern habe ich keinen Bock.
Heute nur 8 Kilometer, anstatt 10, reicht auch.
Back-Weight.
Wieder husten.
Nö, nö, nö, nix.
Kein Husten.
Nur, ich bin immer noch, wie gesagt, ich bin gerade draußen rumgerannt, da dauert das immer ein bisschen, bis man sich wieder dran gewöhnt hat.
So, also, ich muss gerade nochmal mein Vorschau-Rechner anmachen, er blutet gerade, noch was trinken schnell.
Ah, exzellent.
So, aus irgendwelchen Gründen geht...
...meine Maus nicht richtig auf der anderen Seite.
Ah, jetzt, okay.
So.
Ja, Leute, Dienstag, Mittwoch habe ich einen Teambuilding-Workshop, habe ich euch ja gestern schon erzählt.
Irgendwie habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock auf irgendwelche komischen, sinnlos Gruppenspiel-Aktivitäten, die eher nerven, als dass sie unterm Strich was bringen.
Hat irgendjemand schon mal so einen Teambuilding-Workshop gemacht und danach gesagt, boah, das war aber gut.
Das hat sich gelohnt, jetzt arbeiten wir viel besser zusammen.
Also ich noch nicht, zumindest alle, die ich bisher erlebt habe, nicht.
Aber der geilste Workshop, habe ich euch ja immer noch erzählt, habe ich euch ja gestern schon erzählt, ist der, wo wir gegen die Wand gespuckt haben.
Weiß auch nicht, wie sie auf die Idee gekommen sind.
Ah, viels Batman.
Ist super, ja, sehe ich auch so.
Die sind sehr sass, die sind nicht sass-k-ekriege, die sind einfach nur sehr...
...tragwürdig.
So, Vorschau-Rechner ist an.
Exzellent.
Chat gibt wieder Cringe-Jokes am Start.
Also, ich muss mal kurz die E-Mails ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, Arch Linux, by the way, PostChamp, kurz vor M, starten und Package-Updates machen.
Und ich muss immer noch ein bisschen drauf achten, ob vielleicht das Handy klingelt, weil ich bin immer noch, muss immer noch erreichbar sein auf der Arbeit bis Montag 7 Uhr, 7.30 Uhr.
Also, wir hatten auch mal, wir hatten auch mal einen Teambuilding-Workshop, aber das war noch, das habe ich sogar im Video erzählt, glaube ich, zum, ja, doch, doch, glaube ich, habe ich schon mal im Video erzählt, wo wir, ähm, neuen Chef gekriegt haben, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, kurz nach der Ausbildung, könnte sogar noch in der Ausbildung, ich glaube, es war sogar noch in der Ausbildung, ist schon ewig her, wo sie den Workshop gemacht haben, damit wir richtig geiles Team werden, dabei waren wir eigentlich ein richtig gutes Team.
Der einzige, der nicht reingepasst hat, zumindest bis jetzt, war der neue...
Der neue Chef, den sie uns hingesetzt haben, der hatte aber auch gefühlt überhaupt keinen Bock an der Position zu sein und dieser Teambuilding-Workshop sollte einfach nur, war quasi kein Teambuilding-Workshop, sondern Einführung quasi neuer, neuer Teamleiter und da gab es dann solche Fragen, das war richtig cringe, Alter, und die hätte ich heute wahrscheinlich auch nicht anders beantwortet, da gab es dann solche Fragen wie, ja, was würden Sie hier im...
Ich kriege es gar nicht mehr zusammen.
So sinngemäß war die Frage, was würden Sie machen, wenn...
Wenn was irgendwie kaputt geht und...
Ich kriege die Frage nicht mehr zusammen.
Zumindest ging es im Kern bei der Frage darum, wenn mein Chef mir was anderes sagt, als ich für sinnvoll halte, ob ich es dann trotzdem mache oder nicht, so, das war die Frage, ja.
Und da habe ich gesagt, naja, ich würde ihm erstmal sagen, dass ich es nicht für sinnvoll halte und ich meine, wenn er dann drauf besteht, dann würde ich vielleicht ein bisschen meckern, aber...
Letztendlich, wenn er die Verantwortung übernimmt, soll mir recht sein, ja.
Und je nachdem, ich habe halt auch gesagt, je nachdem, was es ist, also, wenn es jetzt darum geht, spring aus dem Fenster, dann nicht, aber wenn das was ist, wofür er die Verantwortung hat und dann haben die sich voll über...
Ich weiß nicht, ich fand die Antwort...
Ehrlich, Leute, ich kann bis heute an dieser Antwort nichts Falsches, nichts Falsches erkennen.
Ich, wirklich, also, seriously, erkennt ihr irgendwas Verwerfliches an dieser Antwort?
Also, ich bis heute nicht.
Zumindest haben sie sich damals übelst drüber aufgeregt, warum man das überhaupt in Frage stellt, was der neue Chef sagt und so.
Das habe ich euch ja auch mal schon im Video erzählt.
Eines der Gründe, eines der Gründe, warum...
Ich habe sie vielleicht nicht ganz so diplomatisch damals verpackt, okay?
Mag sein, mag sein, ja.
Vielleicht habe ich ein bisschen zu kurz und knackig aus...
Also, es ist halt sehr...
Ja, genau.
Wirkliche Antwort.
Haben sie übelst aufgeregt, warum ich das in Frage stelle, was der Chef sagt und sowas.
Ich habe auch gedacht, Alter, ihr habt es nicht mal...
Das war auch echt eines der Gründe, also eines der Mitgründe zu solcher Art von Workshops, warum ich damals da weg bin.
Das war richtig pepege, Alter.
Den Laden gibt es übrigens auch nicht mehr.
Da muss ich kecken.
Ich habe letztens die News gelesen, und letztens ist gut, glaube ich, vor einem Jahr oder so,
dass es meinen ehemaligen Ausbildungsbetrieb nicht mehr gibt.
Der wurde jetzt verkauft an irgendeine...
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Schweizer.
Also nicht verkauft, das stimmt nicht.
Der ist pleite gegangen, und die Reste wurden dann gekauft von irgendeinem Schweizer Rechenzentrumsbetreiber oder so.
Also ich finde das auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und ganz ehrlich, wenn du einen Chef hast, der nicht einfach nur Chef sein raushängen lassen will,
weil die sind meistens eh schlecht auf der Position,
sondern Interesse daran hat, dass das alles gut läuft,
für ihn und für seine Leute und für das Gesamtsystem,
dann hört er auch drauf, was die Leute sagen.
Die Leute sagen, die sich damit auskennen.
Und wenn er nicht darauf hört, dann kann er es zumindest begründen, warum er nicht drauf hört.
Zum Beispiel, ich kann euch was sagen, wo ich auch was gesagt habe,
wo man absichtlich nicht auf mich gehört hat,
aber das hat mich auch nicht aufgeregt, weil ich die Begründung gehört habe.
Und zwar, bei uns haben sie die ganze Zeit erzählt,
Max, Max, mach doch mal einen Call bei Google auf,
warum ein Kubernetes-Cluster so langsam ist.
Und da habe ich gemeint, ey, warum sollen wir da einen Call aufmachen?
Wir wollen den Kram am Ende eh nicht in Kubernetes betreiben.
Sollen wir jetzt doch irgendwie drei Wochen mit rummachen mit,
wir vergleichen Cluster, wir gucken die Version, wir machen Calls bei Google,
wir rufen da unseren Key-Account-Manager an.
Wir wollen es doch eh nicht so betreiben.
Warum machen wir dann da so einen Akt?
Ich finde es total sinnlos, da einen Ticket aufzumachen.
So, und dann haben sie gemeint, so, okay, Max, weißt du was?
Wir verstehen das, wir sehen es ja im Prinzip auch so,
aber mach trotzdem mal ein Ticket auf,
dass wir von Projektseite aus sagen können,
wir haben alles unternommen, was wir machen konnten.
Und wir sagen, okay, also, heißt im Endeffekt, wir sind uns einig, dass es sinnlos ist,
aber damit wir nicht schlecht dastehen, machen wir jetzt einen Ticket auf.
Ja, ja, so ist es.
Aber okay, ey, wenn ihr das wollt, ich mache einen Ticket auf,
aber ich sage euch gleich, bringen tut es nichts.
Kennt ihr solche Situationen?
Das finde ich dann auch okay, ja, das finde ich dann auch okay.
Das ist dann, das ist nachvollziehbar, dass man das machen will.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass man so, seit wann steht da unten jetzt eigentlich Desktop 1 und Desktop 2?
Der stand doch die ganze Zeit immer nicht da.
Für Versicherung, genau.
Also insofern, das, wisst ihr, die Erklärung könntet ihr auch nachvollziehen, oder?
Also was heißt nachvollziehen?
Ihr findet es immer noch ein bisschen unsinnig, aber ihr versteht, warum die das machen wollen, ja?
Und dann sage ich auch, okay, ey, leuchtet mir ein, mache ich, ja?
Wie gesagt, es wird nichts bringen, aber ist okay.
Und das ist, das finde ich dann okay.
Da habe ich überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Also, hast du den Akara-Anwesenheitssensor ausprobiert?
Nein, immer noch nicht.
Ich habe den hier liegen seit drei Monaten oder so.
Hast du den nicht ausprobiert?
Würdest du dir von einem 18-jährigen Schulabbrecher als Chef etwas sagen, dass es nur...
Was?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt nochmal lesen.
Würdest du dir von einem 18-jährigen Schulabbrecher als Chef etwas sagen lassen, er ist nur Chef, der ab der...
Ey, wenn er die Verantwortung für das, was er sagt, übernimmt, klar, warum nicht?
Letztendlich ist er dann dran schuld.
Und wenn du der Sache nicht glaubst, dass er...
Dass er das einhält, was er sagt, dann lass es dir schriftlich geben.
Dann sag ihm, okay, also ich würde aus diesen und diesen Gründen halte ich das für keine gute Idee oder ich würde es so und so machen.
Und wenn er dann sagt, doch, du machst das jetzt, weil ich das so will, dann kannst du ihm im Zweifelsfall immer noch sagen, ja, okay, ich mache das, aber schick mir das doch bitte mal kurz schriftlich.
Und dann ist es okay.
Klar würde ich mir von dem was sagen lassen, wenn er die Verantwortung für das, was er sagt, übernimmt.
So haben wir das Recht.
Nein, ist ja noch besser.
Ist sogar besser für dich, weil wenn er das ein paar Mal macht und immer nur Scheiße entscheidet, dann ist er vielleicht doch wieder weg demnächst, ja.
Wichtig ist immer nur, wenn du Zweifel an sowas hast oder wenn sich schon rausgestellt hat bei den Leuten, dass die öfters mal Blödsinn erzählen und am Ende sich nicht mehr dran erinnern wollen,
sich das schriftlich geben lassen oder zumindest, wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht geht und du es vergessen hast, zumindest, dass du dir das schriftlich notierst,
wann das war und was.
Was er gesagt hat.
Weil das wirkt dann deutlich stichhaltiger.
An der letzten Firma, wo ich war, musste man sich mit sowas immer absichern.
Ich habe zum Beispiel auch oftmals so kleine Protokolle geschrieben bei irgendwelchen Besprechungen.
Entweder nur für mich oder ich habe es am Ende auch rumgeschickt, dass die sich dann nicht wieder so nach dem Motto, ja, nee, so war das doch gar nicht gemeint, aber das hatten wir doch so gar nicht besprochen, irgendwie rausreden konnten.
Das war in der alten Firma, wo ich war, ganz schlimm.
In der neuen glücklicherweise nicht.
Da habe ich das natürlich ein bisschen.
Aber in der Ausprägung nicht erlebt bis jetzt.
Naja, kommt drauf an, wie die das sagen.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch doof.
Ich meine, dann sollte man sich mal die, vielleicht, also je nachdem, wie die das sagen, ja.
Wenn die Leute hinkommen und sagen, alter, seid ihr kacke, hätte ich das jetzt mal vor fünf Jahren schon gemacht, dann würde das alles besser laufen, die unfähigen Kacknoobs.
Dann würde ich ihn auch fragen, ob er noch ganz dicht im Kopf ist.
Aber wenn er sagt, hier, das finde ich, finde ich aus diesen und diesen Gründen nicht optimal gelöst.
Oder nicht so gut, das mache ich ja auf der Arbeit auch, ja.
Und oftmals hatten wir es dann auch schon, ja, okay, ist was dran, aber es ist historisch so gewachsen, aus den und den Gründen ist es schwierig umzusetzen.
Das ist ja, das finde ich kein Problem.
Ich meine, vielleicht hat er ja recht.
Vielleicht hat er ja recht.
Vielleicht ist es auch wirklich doof, wie es bisher gemacht wurde.
Kommt halt drauf an, wie er es sagt.
Man kann, also man kann diese Aussage so und so treffen.
Das beste Beispiel ist immer noch jemand, den wir mal vorlesen.
Wir hatten früher im Team hatten, aus Russland, wir hatten mal drei Russen zwischenzeitlich, drei Kekomrits am Start.
Und einer von denen war super, ultra, der war schon, der war schon so freundlich, dass er kaum was gesagt hat, wenn was schief gelaufen ist.
Das lief dann, Sylvie, danke schön für den Sub, das lief dann ungefähr so, ja.
Der saß, der saß rechts, rechts neben mir.
Und dann hat er mich...
Also nicht immer, immer ist das falsche Wort, gar nicht.
Der hat ab und zu mal halt rüber geguckt.
Und wenn er halt zufälligerweise irgendwie rüber geguckt hat und ihm aufgefallen ist, dass das, was ich da gerade mache, Blödsinn ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel, so, keine Ahnung.
So, also zum Beispiel, ich hätte jetzt hier irgendwie sowas, irgendwie sowas geschrieben hier.
Cut, Süß, Keckel, Reblul.
So.
Und Süß, Keckel gibt's nicht, sondern Brock, Keckel.
Er hätte gesagt, ah, Max, ähm, also der hätte nicht gesagt, das ist Blödsinn, was du da machst.
Er hätte gesagt, ah, also, nee, erstmal hätte er gar nichts gesagt.
Erstmal hätte er gar nichts gesagt.
Erstmal hätte er mich circa 15 Minuten von der Seite immer wieder angeguckt.
Bis ich mich dann zu ihm umgedreht hätte und gesagt, äh, ja, was ist denn, was gibt's denn?
Und dann hätte er gesagt, also Max...
Es gäbe auch andere Möglichkeiten, das zu machen.
Oder sowas, sowas in der Richtung hätte er gesagt.
Also im Prinzip hieß das, das ist übelster Blödsinn, was du gerade schreibst.
Es gäbe auch noch, oder, oder, was hätte er, ja, sowas in der Richtung hätte er gesagt.
Ja, es gäbe andere Möglichkeiten, das zu machen.
Also der war halt ultra vorsichtig.
Der hätte auch sagen können, Max, das funktioniert nicht, was du da gerade probierst.
Oder Max macht nicht so ein Mist oder so, ja.
Aber der hat das immer ultra vorsichtig ausgedrückt, so.
Es gäbe eventuell noch Möglichkeiten, das auch anders zu machen.
So super vorsichtig immer.
Ja, das ist dann halt das Gegenteil.
Ups, jetzt habe ich den Chat-Git zugemacht.
Da ist er wieder.
Ich finde das auch gut.
Ganz ehrlich, mir ist das extrem lieber als das andere Extrem.
Das andere Extrem ist, Alter, ich weiß alles besser und erzählst dir die ganze Zeit, ohne dass ich es wirklich besser weiß.
Ja, genau, so in der Richtung.
So in der Richtung.
Dann hätte er das gesagt, ohne Scheiß.
Man könnte das gegebenenfalls unter Umständen vielleicht auch etwas eleganter lösen.
Ja, ich glaube, das könnte eins zu eins von ihm kommen.
Ja, mir ist das lieb, wie gesagt, das Extreme ist mir lieber.
Es ist echt neu, dass da jetzt Desktop 1 und Desktop 2 steht.
Das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Zumal man sagen muss,
das passt erstaunlich gut zu meinem Linux-Dark-Theme hier vom Terminal, oder?
Sieht fast aus wie die gleiche Farbe.
So, Leute, jetzt ist das vom Rennen endgültig wieder abgeklungen und mir wird es langsam ein bisschen kühl.
Ich mache jetzt mal die Heizung ein Stück hoch noch und ich hole mir mal kurz was zum Überziehen.
So, da bin ich wieder.
Lass uns doch mal gucken, was es auf Shithub so für Trends gibt.
Wir skippen wie immer AI, Machine Learning und diese Geschichten.
Weil langsam hängt es mir zum Hals raus.
Okay, Screenshot to Code, alles klar.
Drop in a Screenshot and convert it to clean HTML.
Was?
Wait, was?
Moment.
App converts a Screenshots?
HTML?
Tell me, CS?
Ah, okay.
Das analysiert was auf.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich.
Das analysiert irgendwie mit GPT-4, was auf dem Screenshot drauf ist und dann generiert das HTML, CSS.
Okay, das ist extremely high IQ.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wann ich das brauche, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, ich bin mir unschlüssig.
Ja, doch, ich weiß wofür.
Das kann man wunderbar benutzen als Beispielplatzhalter auf Webseiten und sowas.
Ja, warum nicht?
Wie gesagt, so einen richtigen Anwendungszweck sehe ich gerade noch nicht, aber es ist cool, dass es sowas gibt.
So, AI ignorieren wir.
AI, Fokus, bestimmt auch AI, wenn ich das hier so lese.
Very good whiteboard, das kenne ich, das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Ja, TL, Draw, da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen gedrawt und das hat es in Local Storage, heißt es im Browser, gespeichert.
Beispielanwendung AppFlowy.
Das.
Rust, Blazingly Fast.
Rust.
Gibt es das auch für Linux?
Ja.
Aber das gibt es nicht für, nicht für iOS, ne?
Oder ist das einfach Markdown, Plaintext, File?
Ne.
Also alles, was es halt auch nicht für Mobile gibt, ja, bringt mir halt...
Ach doch, es gibt es für iOS anscheinend.
Oder auch nicht, mal gucken.
So.
Dann haben wir...
Inferno Metal Shaders for SwiftUI.
Apple, Apple Krempel.
Okay, Apple Things.
Docker für Mac.
Ist Docker unter Mac besser als Docker unter Windows?
Weil Docker unter Windows ist richtig shit.
Potenziell würde ich vermuten, es ist besser, weil es deutlich Unix näher ist alles.
Aber so richtig sicher bin ich mir da nicht.
Spielst du das neue MW3 in Multiplayer?
Nein.
Ich habe mir MW3 nicht gekauft, ihr habt mir MW3 auch nicht kaufen.
Ich habe...
Ich habe ja eigentlich schon seit dem Reboot keinen Bock mehr so richtig drauf,
weil das wirklich an keiner Kreativität nicht mehr zu unterbieten ist.
Man sieht auch, dass sie absolut keinen Bock mehr auf ihr eigenes Game haben.
Es gab doch am Anfang diesen komischen Baum-Skin,
den man auf manchen Maps braun in braun überhaupt nicht gesehen hat,
habe ich auf Reddit gelesen, richtig dumm.
Es muss doch jedem mit ein bisschen Verstand im Hirn der Maps und Skins und Spielsachen-Design auffallen,
dass das eine dumme Idee ist.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, echt kein Bock mehr.
Ja.
Also man muss halt sagen, mich wundert es, dass es gescheit funktioniert,
weil prinzipiell, zumindest ursprünglich,
war Docker ja mal ein, im Prinzip ein Client für Linux-Container.
Und wie das Wort heißt, gibt es das auch nur unter Linux.
Natürlich könnte man, natürlich könnte man,
Docker, das CLI abstrahieren vom jeweiligen Container-Provider-Backend.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch Docker für BSD-Jails oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt es sowas?
Ach, tatsächlich.
Ne, ne, ne, ich habe immer noch nicht reingeguckt.
Das hat tatsächlich, habe ich gesehen, das Spiel halbwegs, halbwegs viele Spieler zur Zeit.
Wobei, ich glaube, es war zwischenzeitlich sogar mal Free-to-Play oder lange Zeit kostenlos.
Irgendwie spielbar oder im Game Pass oder irgendwas in der Richtung war da.
Deswegen hat das immer Steam Charts immer relativ viele Spieler gehabt in letzter Zeit.
Also es geht, das geht echt relativ gut.
Klar, relativ gut klar im Vergleich zu früher, ne.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es im Game Pass drin ist.
So.
Clashcore, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Archived, nice.
Latest version of, ah ja, alles klar.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was das ist.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Aber Zeug, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Das ist irgend so ein Kamera-Gedöns.
Habe ich mir mal angeguckt, hat mir nicht gefallen.
AI, das ist irgendwas für, ne, Machine Learning wahrscheinlich, ne.
Aha, was haben wir denn hier?
Waifu-Mode?
Was, was, was genau bin ich hier sehend?
Was sehe ich?
Ich traue mich nicht, ich traue mich nicht auf die, auf die Webseite zu gehen.
Was, was ist das überhaupt?
Waifu-Mode.
Okay, da kann man, da kann man irgendwelche Bilder generieren wahrscheinlich.
Waifu-Mode, activated.
Was es nicht alles gibt, ha.
So.
Kommen wir mal weiter.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier drin?
Udel, Udel-Book.
Die überspringen wir.
IPTV-Channels, ja, Flutter.
DIVI, AI, AI.
Blockchain-Gedöns.
Liest sich zumindest so.
Power Shell.
Aspire, das ist neues .NET-Zeug, wo ich jetzt ein paar Videos von geguckt habe, aber immer noch nicht so genau weiß, was es jetzt eigentlich ist.
Game-Zeug.
One Panel.
CN.
Ah, China-Chinesen.
One Panel, okay, irgend so ein Admin-Dashboard, was keiner braucht.
Also, ich nicht.
Und Machine Learning.
Das ist ja wirklich nicht sonderlich viel.
Wir gucken mal rein, was es in der .NET-Welt diese Woche neu gibt, weil die hatten ja ihr neues Release und ihre Konferenz diese Woche.
Aspire ist am Start.
Steam-Tools und UI-Blazer.
WPF, Alter.
Okay, immer noch besser als Mami.
Das ist so Dead on Arrival, Alter.
Microsoft und UI-Frameworks, Mensch.
So.
Welche, okay, Chat.
Was, welche Architektur ist das?
Wer ist Cleaner?
Adalis Clean Architecture oder Jason Taylor Clean Architecture?
Das ist jetzt hier die Frage.
Es scheint ein großes Bedürfnis zu sein von .NET-Programmierern, cleane Architektur zu machen.
Dass es da zwei Repos gibt mit 13.000, fast 14.000 Sternen beides.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Windows Optimizer.
Billy, Billy, Billy, Billy.
Ist das nicht das China-YouTube?
Avalonia.
Ja, immerhin mal ein gescheites Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework.
AI, Ding, was man nicht braucht.
Okay, nice, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Nope.
Hat jemand ein Sixth-Head-Empfinden, was man sich vor der FIAN-Prüfung nochmal anschaut?
Ich weiß nicht mal, was FIAN ist.
Das ist Fachinformatiker.
Es ist nicht Anwendungsentwicklung, oder?
Weil das ist F-I-A-E.
Was ist, was ist Fachinformatiker?
Was ist FIAN?
Ist das eines von diesen neun, von diesen zwei neuen Fachinformatikern?
Wie, Vernetzung gibt's da noch?
Und, und, Data, Big Data-Zeug?
Ach doch, Anwendungsentwicklung, okay.
Ja, dann kann ich dir sagen, was du dir angucken sollst vor der Prüfung.
Und zwar das, was ich allen Fisis empfehlen kann.
Äh, nicht nur Fisis, allen Fachinformatikern empfehlen kann.
Einfach alte Prüfungen angucken.
Guck mal, was ist FIAN?
Guck, wo du dir die im Internet saugen kannst.
Du musst die ja offiziell, also offiziell musst du die kaufen, aber du findest sicherlich auch andere Quellen, ja.
Kannst dir die irgendwo runterladen, guckst dir die Prüfungen an und dann, ganz wichtig, die Ergebnisse dazu angucken, ob's passt.
Du musst einfach zwei Wochen lang vor der Prüfung regelmäßig Prüfungen machen.
Und wenn du da ganz gut abschneidest, dann easy, schaffst du ohne Probleme.
Es ist nicht so, dass die Abschlussprüfung schwer ist.
Das Schwierige an der Abschlussprüfung.
Ist, du checken, wie die IHK dumme Fragen stellt.
Und die stellen dumme Fragen.
Vor allem sind die Fragen so dumm, dass du nicht verstehst, was die eigentlich von dir wissen wollen.
Oder du denkst, es ist mehrdeutig, aber die IHK denkt, es ist eindeutig.
Jetzt dann?
Ja, aber das lag nicht an Rust.
So, das mal dicht.
Die IHK saugt, ja, die saugt richtig.
Oh, komm.
Und die Nux küsst mal wieder aus, die brauchen wir jetzt.
Ach, komm, lass mal an.
Schade auch nicht, ich hab genug RAM.
Mein Browser frisst noch nicht genug RAM.
Es muss unbedingt...
Ich brauch mehr.
Wie viel RAM ist belegt?
Ja.
Nix.
Guck mal.
Nur 41,8 von 67.
Keck, wait.
Also, ich mein ernsthaft.
Was soll das?
Das ist ja fast die Hälfte vom RAM noch frei.
Ich würd sagen, wir brauchen noch mehr Browser, noch mehr Tabs und vor allem noch mehr VMs,
dass das irgendwie sich auch mal lohnt, 64 GB RAM zu haben.
Bist du schon mehr Entwickler als Admin, also mehr DevOps als Ops?
Nö.
Also, im aktuellen, naja, je nachdem, wie man's, also, ich würd sagen, im aktuellen Job eher nicht.
Aber, also, im letzten eindeutig, im aktuellen Job vielleicht nicht.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, so richtig viel ganz klassisches Admin-Zeug ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Also, es ist viel mehr Infra-, Cloud-Infrastruktur und Automatisierung.
Und ich hab ja auch schon die ein oder anderen Tools programmiert, unter anderem nen AMQP-Client in Go.
Also, ja.
Also, halbe, halbe, ja.
Aber ich sag's ja oft genug, dass die Überschneidungen werden immer größer.
Das, das war irgendwas anderes.
Das war irgendwas mit, dass er mein Icon für die Seite nicht findet.
Das ist nicht schlimm, das passt alles.
Also, es geht, es geht ja jetzt mittlerweile auch.
Hast du den RAM-Spar-Modus aktiviert?
Wenn es Default ist, ja, ich hab da nix dran umgestellt.
Und es ist ja auch sinnvoll, dass die Tabs, die du nicht aufmachst, nicht aufmachst.
Wenn du die nicht aufgemacht hast seit zwei Monaten, ja, dass die nicht gleich automatisch in den RAM geladen werden.
Das macht ja schon Sinn.
Echt.
Ja.
Übrigens, habt ihr's gelesen?
Manifest 3.
Die machen wieder einen neuen Anlauf mit dem Scheiß.
Es soll, es, das ist das, wo, wo U-Block nicht mehr richtig unterstützt wird.
Ja.
Ich letztens, ja.
Das heißt, bald müssen wir alle wieder Firefox, Firefox usen.
Achso, ach.
Sie haben, okay, sie haben ein bisschen rück, rückgerudert wieder.
Aber es ist, es ist ganz einfach, Leute.
Sollte Chrome es wirklich unmöglich machen, dass man Adblocker verwendet.
Also, also, nicht, dass man, dass man Adblocker verwenden kann, die gescheit funktionieren.
Dann ist halt einfach wieder Firefox-Time.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre Firefox schlecht.
Ich hab Firefox drauf, ich hab Chromium drauf, ich hab Chromium drauf.
Wenn Chromium baut, hoffentlich dann wieder aus, falls man das ausbauen kann.
Oder baut das andere wieder.
Nein.
Aber eine Sache sieht man daran.
Es ist gar nicht mal so geil, wenn die gesamte Macht über die ganze, über sowas komplett bei Google liegt.
In dem Fall ist es halt, sagen wir mal, nur YouTube und der Browser, mit dem man guckt.
Aber es ist schon viel, ja, viel sehr zentriert.
Du kannst dich bei Android und bei iOS kaum noch dagegen wehren, quasi, dich dem zu ergeben, was dein, was dein Smartphone-Hersteller will.
Und hier hast du auch nicht viele, viele Chancen.
Wenn, wenn halt die Client-Software und die Plattform vom gleichen Anbieter kommt, da können die fast machen, was sie wollen.
Ja, das, dass er da ein Video zugemacht hat, wundert mich nicht.
Der ist ja immer am Start bei sowas.
Moin, Kami.
Wie wär's mit einem Linux-Desktop-Customization-Video?
Ich hab keinen Desktop.
Ich hab, ich hab einen Terminal und einen Browser.
Und, und einen Tiling-Window-Manager.
Und die, die Sachen, die sind relativ einfach zu customizen, weil da hab ich meine Config-Files dafür auf Shithub.
Also Desktop kann ich nicht groß customizen.
Das, das, das, das, das Customizigste bei mir sind die Bilder im Hintergrund und die, und die Leiste hier oben.
Stimmt, und außerdem haben wir, nee.
Ach so, ja, das lag daran, das lag, das, das, das, das lag daran, weil das so viel Daten geschickt hat.
Weil der Player nie angefangen hat zu play, zu playen.
Das ging danach dann schon.
Hab ich ausge-, hab ich ausprobiert alle fünf Varianten davon.
War okay, aber nicht so nice, dass ich's behalten hätte.
Ich hab seit Jahren schon als Color-Theme, äh, Tomorrow Night, Base 16, Tomorrow Night, eher im Terminal.
Da hab ich mich so dran gewöhnt.
Ich find das, ich find das auch nice.
Ja, also die Farben gefallen mir gut von dem, vom Kontrast her ist es eigentlich genau richtig.
Und jetzt, seitdem ich mein Terminal so halb transparent im Hintergrund habe, find ich das auch nice.
Weil dann sieht man den Pepo durchgucken.
Übrigens, musste einer auch letztens gezwungenes Windows-Update machen, seitdem man hier auch die Desktop-Anzeige kriegt.
Und war bei jemand, also, war bei euch auch das Desktop-Hintergrundbild weg?
Heute Morgen, ich hab gestern Abend meinen Rechner runtergefahren, Windows-Update gemacht.
Und heute Morgen gestartet, Desktop-Hintergrund weg.
Und jetzt, muss ich dann neu setzen, weil Windows der Meinung war,
na, Desktop-Hintergrund ist overrated, jebaited.
Was findest du schicker, GCC oder, ist mir vollkommen egal.
Das, was funktioniert.
In der Regel ist es meistens GCC bei mir, weil, wenn ich mit C und C++ was mache, ist es meistens für den ESP32.
Und das ist halt ein Compiler, der auf GCC basiert.
Moin, RushTV.
Og, ja.
Moin, Nara.
Jetzt sind sie alle da, hier.
So, Chat-Game.
Hm.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Das können wir uns dann angucken.
Erstaunlich.
Raspberry Pi 5 kann PS2 und Wii.
Ja, kann meine Kiste auch.
Das wollte ich mir mit euch nachher mal angucken.
Linux, wir skippen das ein bisschen.
Wir gucken uns das nicht komplett im Detail an.
Sowas wollte ich nämlich auch machen, so ein Video.
Und ich bin mal gespannt.
Bin mal gespannt, was...
Ob ich da, ob ich d'accord gehe damit, ja?
Die Frage, die ich mir stelle ist, erkenne ich überhaupt anhand der Icons die ganzen Distributionen.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Ich kann die Hälfte, glaube ich, nicht mal zuordnen.
Okay.
Also, Debian Arch.
Nochmal irgendeinen Arch oder so?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, das ist Peppermint, glaube ich.
Das ist die unsinnigste Distribution überhaupt.
Das ist PopOS, das ist Puppi-Linux.
Das ist PopOS, das ist Popo.
Das ist Linux PC OS oder wie das heißt.
Suse MonkaS, Alter.
Jubantu.
Twitter OS.
Ähm.
Fedora.
Red Hat.
Kein, kein.
Das da hinten könnte Manjaro sein.
Das ist, ist das, ist das Kali gewesen hier?
Kali hat, ne, Kali hat aber.
Die hatten doch auch so ein Logo.
Ne, Kali sind die mit dem, mit dem Drache, gell?
Wieder was anderes.
Ey, das ist Kali, oder?
Oh, das ist Gentoo.
Das ist Gentoo, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keinen Plan.
Das kommen wir uns gleich mal an.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Ah, guck mal da.
Fireship hat ein neues Video.
Das, das müssen wir uns jetzt, müssen wir uns.
Zur Gemüte führen.
Ey.
Alles, was, Leute.
Deswegen gibt es auf Dauer keine nicen Sachen, ey.
Die Leute storen ihre Files mittlerweile auf YouTube.
Encoded.
Ja.
Auf GitHub.
Auf Discord, man.
Okay, komm, das, das kommen wir uns jetzt mal an.
Richtiger Hacker-Man-Content hier wieder.
Ja, das hatte ich auch schon.
Da habe ich einfach Sachen, die 15 Jahre alt waren, gelöscht.
... Data Allocation and encouraging me to give Google just a little bit of money for some more storage.
... Storage.
Looking at their plans, these are actually not too terribly expensive.
And storage prices are currently at historic lows, so I could even buy myself a terabyte or so for a pretty reasonable price.
But you know what's an even more reasonable price?
Zero dollars.
So using a bit of software engineering know-how, I wisely traded tens of hours of my life and much of the sanity I had left to avoid spending probably 50 dollars.
Here's how I managed to store hundreds of gigabytes of my files on Discord for free.
If you're like me, you have a lot of files, and you're probably getting pretty close to the free limits for iCloud or Google Drive, if you're not already paying for extra storage.
But I've been thinking...
Aber ehrlich, ich glaube früher oder später, also Discord ist ja nicht blöd.
Ich meine, die können das auch feststellen und so eine Abfrage in ihrer Datenbank dürfte auch nicht so schwer sein, falls sie da überhaupt eine Datenbankabfrage für machen müssen.
Welcher Account?
Welcher Accounts sind für den Storage verwendet?
... für den Storage für den Free?
Warum kann man nicht viel Free Storage bekommen?
Wenn du dir das vorstellst, ist jede Social Media Plattform wirklich nur ein Ort, wo du deine Files oder Content uploaden kannst, wenn du das möchtest, und andere Leute schauen, oder?
Facebook, YouTube, Instagram, alles gleich.
Du uploadest deine Files und teilst sie mit Leuten.
Die wichtige Sache hier zu behalten ist, dass diese Unternehmen meistens die Fileszahlen oder Quanten pro Post beweisen, aber sie limitieren nicht die Anzahl der Daten, die ein einziger User oder Account uploaden kann.
Und wir können das auch machen.
Wir können die Gelegenheit absolut ver trendy verwenden, dass wir so viel Storage wie möglich kosten können, ohne nichts.
ohne nichts.
Mein erster Wahlkandidat für eine Plattform, um Storage zu zahlen, war YouTube.
war YouTube.
YouTube lässt dir Videos frei verleihen und jeder kann 256 GB oder 12 Stunden lang sein, weshalb auch immer zu typed, also das erinnert sich als eine gute Lösung, viele 256 GB Leitungen zu haben.
とか viele 256 GB Leitungen zu haben.
Natürlich würde das nur für Videofile funktionieren, also benötigt es eine Art, meine Daten, wie Worddocs, Textfile, Bilder usw. um Video zu konvertieren.
Und das heißt, wir müssen auf diese Art arbeiten.
Ja, da gibt es ja schon was.
Ja, deswegen ist es auch, wahrscheinlich hat sich das noch nicht so richtig etabliert.
Basically hat CDN halt also das Text- und Voice-Chat.
Never sub, never donate.
Free storage, she baited.
Siehste, das ist schon der erste Fehler.
Es ist nicht in Rust.
Also kann es nicht blazingly fast sein.
Moin, warum hast du das Tab-Grouping immer noch an, weil ich es nicht ausgeschaltet habe?
Ich hab's ja schon.
Ich glaube halt nicht, dass es dauerhaft wirklich funktioniert, dass das Discord dauerhaft mit sich machen lässt.
Aber es ist jetzt nix, wo man sagen würde, super krass um die Ecke gedacht, einfach nur einmal groß um die Ecke gedacht, dass man das ja machen könnte.
Ich glaube, dass die Umsetzung gar nicht so kompliziert ist.
Er könnte ein geteiltes Zip-Archiv machen, ist doch egal, ob er ein geteiltes Zip-Archiv macht oder ob er die Dateien so splittet.
Wichtig ist nur, dass er sie am Ende wieder zusammenfügt, was er bei beidem machen muss.
Entklippten!
Aber es tut nicht schaden, extra sicher zu sein.
Selbst wenn niemand auf meinem Server ist, ist es hypothetisch möglich,
zum Beispiel, dass die IRS später dieses Jahr, wenn die Taxi-Saison kommt,
und sie alle meine sensiblen Taxi-Dokumente sehen können, mit meinen Plänen, um Taxi-Fraude zu verurteilen.
Ich möchte das natürlich nicht, also wäre es gut, meine Daten zu verstecken.
Glücklicherweise kann ich das ziemlich schnell machen.
Jedes Stück File, das ich encode, wird entkriptet.
Dann, wenn ich das File zurücklese, kann ich es dekriptieren
Da habe ich mir schon fast gedacht, dass sowas jetzt kommt.
...ein Stück entkriptieren, bevor ich es wieder zusammenlege.
Nun kann niemand sehen, was die Daten, die ich schreibe, tatsächlich sind.
Wenn sie die Messungsabschlüsse anschauen, sehen sie nur ein paar randome Symbole und Charaktere.
Jetzt, dass ich alles entkodet habe, ist das letzte, was noch zu tun ist,
all meine Daten zu uploaden.
Das ist nicht besonders schnell.
Nein, lass uns mal reden.
Zuerst muss ich das File durch meinen Browser in den Backend-Server uploaden,
was ein bisschen Zeit dauert.
Danach muss der Server das ganze File lesen, es in Trunks brechen und es entkriptieren,
was auch Zeit dauert.
Dann muss ich alle Trunks auf Discord uploaden, was noch mehr Zeit dauert.
Ich habe einen Status-Bar eingegeben, damit ich weiß, ob etwas tatsächlich passiert ist,
denn Uploads und Downloads können mehrere Stunden dauern.
Aber letztendlich habe ich alle File ohne viel Zeit geübt.
Jetzt sprechen wir über die Leistung.
Wenn ich es auf ein Wort beschreiben müsste, wäre es...
Es ist lahm-ass-fuck.
...eh.
Ich habe einen Speedtest gemacht und für ein 55 GB-File
hat es 2,5 Stunden gedauert, um es zu uploaden.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Das ist nicht so...
Das ist nicht so schlecht?
Das ist ungefähr 2 Minuten und 45 Sekunden pro GB.
Das ist definitiv langsam, aber nicht zu schlecht, glaube ich.
Ja.
Downloads sind etwas schneller.
Wir schauen ungefähr 1 Minute und 40 Sekunden pro GB, um es zu downloaden.
Das ist wiederum ziemlich okay.
Und wahrscheinlich viel schneller.
Leute, das wäre ja absolut nächstes Level.
Man könnte sich...
Okay, okay, passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Man könnte die Dateien indexieren,
mit in 4 KB-Chunks
und sich den Hash speichern.
Schad 256 Hash von 4K-Chunks.
Und dann sich diesen Index speichern lokal
und jede Datei, die neu in den Server eingelesen wird,
gucken, ob die identische Hashes hat.
Jedes Mal, wenn du die in 4K splittest.
Und wenn es identische Hashes hat, die nicht hochladen...
Dann musst du aber halt irgendwie das Ganze tracken,
wo du welche Datei laden musst, an welcher Stelle du extrahieren musst,
dass du an den richtigen gehst.
Also, das macht die Sache ultra kompliziert.
Aber gehen wird das Ganze.
Und wahrscheinlich würde es auch ein bisschen Speicher dann sparen.
Das ist ein sehr geistiges Projekt.
In Bezug auf Datenintegrität und Longevität
scheint alles gut zu sein.
Es scheint nicht, dass meine Daten gesperrt sind.
Es hat mich ein paar Monate gedauert, um das alles zu machen.
Aber in dieser Zeit, die erste Datei, die ich für Testen veröffentlicht habe,
ist immer noch ohne Problem.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, man müsste im Server jetzt noch einbauen,
dass der für jede Datei, so sagen wir mal, einmal in der Woche
einen Download startet und abbricht,
dass Discord merkt, das File ist noch aktiv.
Ja, wahrscheinlich löschen sie es dann auch nicht,
wenn sie merken, das File ist noch aktiv.
Ein kurzer Hinweis hier.
Es ist ein paar Monate später, als ich das editiere,
und Discord hat gerade angekündigt, dass sie verändern werden,
wie externe CDN-Linke funktionieren.
Oh!
Discord hat schon Malware auf Discord gehostet.
Nun, CDN-Linke außerhalb von Discord werden nach 24 Stunden abgeholt werden,
aber Linke innerhalb von Discord funktionieren immer noch.
Ich plane ein Follower-Video, nachdem sie das verändern,
weil es möglich ist, dass es abgeholt wird, was ich hier tue,
aber ich denke tatsächlich, dass es nicht so sein wird.
Also achtet auf das in der nächsten Zukunft.
So, das war's, wie ich alle Follower auf Discord veröffentliche.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Man muss gar nichts bahnbrechend Neues erfinden.
Man muss einmal nur an der richtigen Stelle um die Ecke denken,
und schon hat man was Cooles created.
The most loved tech-Stack. Cobol.
Cobol mit Postgres.
Ja, definitiv.
Postgres, Cobol und Rust.
Das ist, glaube ich, ja, das ist mit Abstand der beste Tech-Stack aller Zeiten.
Also quasi Cobol, Rust, Postgres.
Also Ritzp.
Deine Ritzp-Stack.
Was ist das?
Chainsaw.
So, here is...
Okay, das 6 in 30 Minuten, das gucken wir jetzt nicht,
aber ich lasse es mal auf.
Wie heißt dein Cursor bei Arch?
Habe ich das nicht committet auf Shithub?
Lass uns mal gucken.
Wenn nicht, so müsste ich es mal committen.
Cursor.
Hier, da steht es doch.
Chatge.
Bibata Modern...
Amber.
Heißt der.
POG Cursor.
Cursor Größe 24.
Das ist kein Cursor, das ist ein POG Cursor.
Ein...
Cursor.
Keine Ahnung, das kann man nicht zusammenpappen, die Wörter.
POG POG Cursor.
Ne.
So. Aber der ist nice.
Und ich habe das absichtlich
auf Orange,
aber ich habe ja überall Dark Theme
und ich finde Orangen Cursor sieht man einfach gut.
Ah, jetzt auf dem Hintergrund so,
dann machst du ja auch nichts.
Ich habe ja eh keinen Desktop, das heißt es macht gar keinen Sinn.
Es macht gar keinen Sinn für mich,
hier auf dem Desktop rumzuklicken.
Außer mir den nicen Pepo, der gerade Cursor spottet, anzugucken.
Cursor Pepo.
Das ist E3, ja.
Dementsprechend ist es auch kein Wayland,
weil Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und sie sich immer noch am Blame-Gamen sind
gegenseitig, wer jetzt die Schulter dran hat.
Lul.
Warum kein Dualboot?
Warum soll ich Dualboot machen?
Ist doch viel besser, wenn ich live switchen kann
zwischen Linux und Windows, ohne zu rebooten.
Das ist quasi
wie Dualboot, nur ohne Dualboot.
Quasi Dualboot less Dualboot.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Linux Tierlist.
Komm, wir geben uns jetzt die
Linux Tierlist, allerdings
ein bisschen, ein bisschen schneller.
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass wir 27
mal gucken, mal gucken, wie schnell er das macht.
We choose violence,
when we do a Linux Tierlist.
People get really upset,
especially when...
Da gebe ich ihm recht, weil jeder meint,
die Distribution, die er benutzt, ist halt das Beste.
Dabei haben die alle keine Ahnung.
Wir wissen alle, dass Arch-Dealings das Beste ist.
Also wenn ihr was anderes benutzt
und meint, eure Distribution ist das Beste,
habt ihr objektiv gesehen Unrecht.
Korrekt? Chat?
Any Archers?
Liste?
Okay, auf geht's.
When it's an honest Tierlist,
Gebe ihm einen Arsch.
Gebe ich ihm Recht?
Liste? Liste? Der macht's richtig.
Also, ich muss gleich dazu
sagen, dass ich bei solchen Tierlists
eigentlich egal welche...
Letztens haben wir eine Tierlist gesehen,
Programmiersprachen.
Das war, glaube ich, die unsinnigste Tierlist,
die ich ever gesehen habe.
Die wichtigsten Sprachen nicht dabei
und komplett bescheuert sortiert.
Ich glaube immer noch,
dass das Video absichtlich gemacht wurde,
um Leute zu triggern.
Ich stimme solchen Tierlists meistens nicht zu.
Gucken wir mal.
Aber dem Pick stimme ich definitiv zu.
Debian und Arch.
S-Tier.
Debian auf dem Server.
S-Tier. Arch auf dem Desktop. S-Tier.
Nothing else goes in the S-Tier.
Debian, Arch, when it comes to Linux, Desktop...
Desktop?
Okay.
Naja, was auch immer.
Ich würde es umgedreht sagen. Arch auf dem Desktop,
Debian auf dem Server.
Ubuntu auf dem Server geht auch, klar.
So wie auch
meinetwegen Red Hat, wenn's unbedingt sein muss.
Wenn man auf Red Hat Bock hat.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
genau das ist meine
Kombi. Server, Debian, Arch,
Desktop.
Ich habe eine ganze Zeit lang Ubuntu Server verwendet,
bis ich dann irgendwann den Grund überhaupt
nicht mehr erkannt habe,
warum ich Ubuntu verwende auf dem Server.
Früher habe ich Ubuntu gerne verwendet,
weil die immer einen Ticken moderner waren
als Debian.
Aber das ist zwar immer noch so,
aber eigentlich nicht mal so richtig relevant.
Und Ubuntu hat
einige Sachen, die mich abfacken.
Zum Beispiel Netplan
oder Browser nur noch als Snaps.
Und ja, das fuckt mich auch auf dem Server ab.
Weil ich will zum Beispiel mal
trotzdem ein Firefox installieren
für X-Forwarding oder sowas.
Aus Gründen, wo man es vielleicht mal braucht.
Aber das geht unter Ubuntu dann nicht gescheit.
Und Netplan ist eh die dümmste Idee
ever, Alter. YAML-Config für irgendwie
IP. Das ist so dämlich, Mann.
Also deswegen
Ubuntu. Deswegen bin ich irgendwann mal
zu Debian geswitcht.
Vor ein paar Jahren wieder. Für Serversysteme.
Und seitdem wüsste ich nicht,
ob ich was anderes haben möchte.
Was macht denn Arch für dich?
Ob ich das direkt sehen kann?
Oh, da gibt es einige Sachen.
Also erstmal der Package Manager.
Das ist mit Abstand, ich habe jetzt leider keine Package mehr
zum Updaten. Das ist mit Abstand der schnellste
und einfachste und beste Package Manager, den es gibt.
Du hast User Repos.
Dass du,
also wenn es was nicht als ganz
offizielle Packages gibt, hast du User Repos.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel
suchen nach kekw.
Okay, da gibt es nix.
Twitch, irgendwas, was weiß ich.
Und da hast du
tausend von Usern
bereitgestellte Anwendungen,
die du dir installieren kannst.
Die nicht offiziell von dem
Distributionshersteller kommen, aber du hast,
ich glaube, also ich würde mal behaupten,
ich kann das nicht mit Zahlen belegen, aber du hast
für Arch Linux mit Abstand
die größte Package Auswahl, die es gibt.
Es gibt eigentlich fast nix,
was es nicht gibt für Arch Linux.
Und
das ist die Kombination.
Du hast einen super Paket Manager,
du hast alle Software, die du brauchst,
du hast modernste Packages, modernste Kernel,
modernste Software-Versionen.
Du hast
ein super Customizable System
und
eigentlich
deswegen ist Arch Linux das Beste.
Also auf dem Desktop, auf dem Desktop.
Also auf dem Server
sieht es für mich anders aus.
Ich mag auf dem Server Debian am liebsten.
Debian aus den Gründen, die glaube ich der Chat
auch gerade schon genannt hat.
Zum Beispiel Debian funktioniert.
Debian ist bei allem irgendwie supported.
Debian hat mittlerweile auch alles dabei, was man braucht.
Zum Beispiel haben die mittlerweile auch ZFS und sowas
dabei. Haben wir letztens auf der Arbeit sogar erst
gebraucht, weil wir zu wenig Storage hatten.
ZFS.
Und Debian funktioniert einfach.
Und eine Sache,
die ich noch nie hatte bei Debian,
bei anderen
Distributionen schon, ist, dass
bei einem Update irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist.
Bei mir ist legit, bei Debian,
ich weiß nicht, Chat, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Bei mir ist unter Debian
noch nie irgendwas bei einem Update
kaputt gegangen.
Noch nie. Das ging einfach immer.
Red Hat hat es schon auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ubuntu erst recht.
Ja. Debian noch nie.
Also es gibt,
ich kann mich nicht an einen Fall erinnern,
dass Debian irgendwann, irgendwie mal
kaputt gegangen ist. Noch nie.
Ja. Also.
Deswegen. Deswegen finde ich,
wir waren übrigens gerade mal beim Video
gucken.
Gebe ich ihm da voll und ganz recht.
Debian, Arch Linux,
S-Tier.
Arch auf dem Desktop, Debian auf dem Server.
Ja, es gibt schon so ein... Chat.
Moment, hier.
Ja, es gibt schon so ein paar Sachen, da muss man sich dran gewöhnen.
Aber ist doch kein Ding.
Ja, installierst du nach
und gut ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ich musste letztens auf der Arbeit diskutieren,
ob wir nicht TMAX als
Default-Paket auf alle unsere Server drauf hauen können.
Da kam der erste um die Ecke und meinte,
oh nein, aber Screen-Reihe,
ich doch. Ja, als würde jetzt irgendwie
so ein 50 KB Package
Probleme machen oder so.
Gut, sollen sie machen, was sie wollen.
Also, das finde ich nicht so schlimm,
dass Curl nicht drauf ist,
WGAT nicht drauf ist bei dem einen und bei dem anderen.
Muss auch immer gucken, was man für Images verwendet,
wenn du beispielsweise die Debian Cloud Images
verwendest.
Die sind super minimalistisch.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob der 4M-Champ noch
funktioniert. Gucken. Gucken, ob's
auch klappt, ja. Das ist ein Debian 11
Cloud Image. Das ist halt
super minimalistisch. Dementsprechend lässt sich
das auch schnell runterladen.
Und da ist halt nichts drauf.
Standardmäßig. Also gut wie nichts.
Mr. S. N. Alive.
Danke für den Sub.
Aber das Gute ist,
es ist ein minimal
lauffähiges System. Und du kannst
es halt customisieren. Deswegen finde ich Debian,
wenn du mich fragst, ich mag Debian als
Base für Container Images auch lieber
als Alpine. Alpine hat ja
bekanntermaßen öfters mal DNS-Probleme.
Ja. Genau.
Ja. Aber Alpine hat ja
öfters mal DNS-Probleme
und Debian ist ein...
Das ist so No-Brain. Du kannst Debian benutzen
und es geht. Guck mal. Ich mein, wenn du hier
mal drückst, es ist halt
nix dabei. Curl. Doch. Guck mal.
Curl ist beim Cloud Image standardmäßig dabei.
Wer hat erzählt, dass Curl nicht dabei ist?
Curl ist dabei.
Weget ist auch dabei.
Also Leute, wenn bei dem Cloud Image
Curl dabei ist, dann kann's nicht
so super minimalistisch sein.
Heck, wait.
Welche VM benutzt du? Vmware Workstation.
Ja, das macht
bei
DNS-Auflösung öfters Probleme.
Da gibt's regelmäßige so
Heul-Threads auf Reddit.
Wenn mal wieder irgendeiner, frag mich nicht,
5 MB DNS-Antworten
hat, dann kackt Alpine
wieder richtig rein.
Ist Tmux auch dabei? Nee, glaub ich
nicht. Ist Screen dabei?
Screen ist dabei. Ich weiß auch warum.
Weil
Upt
verwendet
mittlerweile Screen, wenn du
Sachen upgradest.
Oder installierst. Upt install
Tmux.
Guck, das hier ist Screen.
Deswegen ist das, glaub ich,
Screen mittlerweile dabei.
Gut, dann löschen wir die Debian-VM mal wieder.
Benutzt ihr Monitoring-Software
auf der Arbeit? Ja, welche hast...
Ich kann nicht lesen.
Schrecklich gerade.
Benutzt ihr Monitoring-Software
auf der Arbeit? Wenn ja, welche
falls du das... Ich glaube nicht, dass es da Probleme gibt,
wenn ich das sage. Schreibe gerade
eine 15-seitige Hausarbeit über das Thema
und würde mich mal freuen. Also, es gibt
ja zig Sachen, die man verwendet.
Also, ich muss
die Antwort jetzt leider ein bisschen länger machen.
Angefangen hab ich
mal mit Nagios. Das war noch während
der Ausbildung beim Provider. Nagios.
Und ihr kennt mich, ich hab immer noch ein
weiches Herz für Nagios.
Ich würde nicht unbedingt
zwangsläufig einen neuen Nagios heutzutage
aufsetzen wollen.
Aber ich mag Nagios.
So, Nagios. Dann haben wir Zabbix
gemacht. Und in letzter Zeit
hauptsächlich Prometheus.
Allerdings muss man auch mal ehrlich
sagen, Prometheus
ist gut für Metriken.
Man kann damit quasi auch alles andere
monitoren, aber merkt irgendwie permanent,
dass es dafür nicht gemacht ist.
Für so, is up, is down,
port offen, port zu. Das geht
mit Prometheus, aber
Prometheus musst du sehr viel selbst stricken.
Das geht mit sowas wie Nagios oder Zabbix
oder Checkmk. Checkmk ist
übrigens auch das, was wir auf der Arbeit
zurzeit zwar nicht ausschließlich,
aber zumindest
größeren Stil verwenden.
Zabbix ist auch komplett insane.
Das Problem an Zabbix ist,
dass
die Logik hinter der Konfig
keine Sau kapiert. Nicht mal die
Leute verstehen ihre Logik. Ich habe mal
irgendeine Zabbix Release Version
Ankündigungsvideo gesehen von denen.
Zabbix kommt ja aus
aus Lettland oder Litauen
oder so kommen die glaube ich.
Und
fällt mir nur gerade ein.
Der Typ hat das in dem Video
gezeigt und da wusste er selbst in dem Video
nicht, wo er klicken muss in seine Web Interface.
Also Zabbix Web Interface
ich kenne niemanden, der das Zabbix
Web Interface checkt. An sich finde ich
Zabbix wirklich nice. Zabbix
integriert nahezu alles was man braucht.
Leider
halt super weird
Web Interface um zu konfigurieren.
Und das
was Graphen angeht
und Dashboards ist halt Grafana immer noch
meilenweit besser. Es wäre halt mega
wenn Zabbix da ein bisschen aufholt.
Muss ja gar nicht auf das Niveau aufholen
von Grafana.
Und vielleicht mal ein ordentliches
Web Interface auf die Reihe kriegt,
was irgendwie ein bisschen logisch ist.
Dann wäre Zabbix wirklich wunderbar geeignet
als so
gerade auch im Heimbereich
und sagen wir mal, wenn es jetzt nicht so super groß wird
Bereich als einzige
Monitoringlösung, wo man sonst nichts mehr
dabei braucht.
Ich habe mit der
neuen Nagios Version gar nicht so viele Erfahrungen.
Ich kenne die alten
noch aus Zeiten, wo Nagios Net Saint hieß.
Das war quasi so
1999 oder so.
Fragt mich nicht.
Nagios, wann hieß
das so?
Ja, Net Saint hieß
das früher.
Ich glaube, da gibt es gar keine Version History.
Wann haben die das umbenannt?
Das ist uralt.
Ja, weiß man nicht.
Das war
auch schon ein bisschen vor meiner Zeit.
Aber wir hatten noch einen Nagios, der noch
ein Net Saint im Einsatz damals.
Uptime Kuma finde ich
eine super Geschichte für Leute,
die Sachen daheim selbst hosten.
Das einzig Blöde an
Uptime Kuma für mich ist,
dass so ein paar Features,
die ich gerne hätte,
mir fehlen.
Nämlich,
ich hätte gerne sowas wie
Zeig mir an,
wenn die Festplatte im Wohnzimmer
voll läuft. Das kann Uptime Kuma
nicht. Uptime Kuma ist genau für das da,
wofür es da ist, nämlich
simple Checks zu machen.
Host Up, Down, Ping da, Port da.
Leider kann man auch keine Remote Checks
gescheit ausführen, dass man sagen würde,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es mittlerweile
die Möglichkeit hat, über
sowas zu machen. Vermutlich
nicht.
Ey, Push Monitor suckt.
Ja, das ist blöd.
Und man hat auch keine History und sowas.
Also für einfache Up-Down-Shakes top,
aber spätestens so wie, ich würde gerne
sehen, ob meine Festplatte voll läuft oder
vielleicht auch mal gucken, wie die den letzten
Monat über voll gelaufen ist, kannst du damit nicht machen.
Deswegen, ich habe daheim auch Zabbix im Einsatz,
weil ich keinen Bock habe auf mehrere Lösungen,
auf mehrere Sachen.
Aber Zabbix ist
abfuck. Ich mag Zabbix nicht.
Aber es ist das einzige, was so als
ja, All-in-One-Lösung gescheit bei mir
funktioniert.
Wie ist deine Software auf der Arbeit?
Prometheus, ja? Ah ne, auf der Arbeit
Checkmk haben wir da.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde Checkmk
nicht so geil. Kommt drauf an,
was du machen willst. Willst du eher
Metriken auswerten oder willst du eher
so alte klassische
Up-Down-Checks machen? Also willst du
zum Beispiel gucken, ist der Port
offen, antwortet der Web-Server,
pingt die Kiste,
steht in der Web-Response
irgendwas drin? Dafür ist
Checkmk und Zabbix und sowas
ganz gut. Willst du Metriken einsammeln?
Ja?
Metriken können zum Beispiel auch sein,
wie ist der Verlauf von
meiner CPU-Last über mehrere
Monate?
Oder gar beispielsweise, wenn du
Anwendungen überwachen willst, so
wie wegen der Java-Anwendung, wie sind
die Garbage-Collector-Runs? Da ist
Prometheus einfach unschlagbar.
So, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Eigentlich wollte ich mich da gar nicht so
sehr drüber auslassen. Jetzt gucken wir mal
das Video mit der Linux-Tierlist weiter.
Halten wir mal fest, ich stimme ihm komplett zu.
Debian Arch Linux S-Tier.
Weiter.
Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, müsst ihr das mal mit
nwublos in den Chat schreiben.
Korrekt.
Gerade, wir usen Arch, by the way,
das lass ich auch nicht debaten.
Es gibt manche Leute, die sagen,
es muss Gentoo sein.
Wir haben ne Arch-Linux-Gruppe
auf der Arbeit. Ja, aber da sind nur drei Leute drin.
Wir kriegen auf der Arbeit ja
Windows vorgesetzt. Und was für ein
Windows, Leute. So ein verhunztes
Windows hab ich selten gesehen, ey.
40.000 Viren-Scanner
im Hintergrund. Alles ist
super langsam, man. Ich arbeite nur noch auf
meiner Linux-VM.
Ja, du kennst das, ne?
Ich arbeite nur auf
meiner VM. Alles andere halt ich nicht aus.
Leute, ich rate mal,
in Evil geht wahrscheinlich nur
Red Hat bei ihm.
Garantiert packt er, äh, nicht Evil,
Devil, Devil.
Kommt uns gleich in dem Fall raus. Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es dieses Tier nur gibt,
damit er Red Hat reinpacken kann.
Ich kenne niemand,
der von, der überzeugter
Mac-User war und zu Linux
gewechselt ist.
Also bei mir ist umgedreht.
Ich bin Linux-User und hab
eigentlich gar keinen großen Bock drauf, Mac zu
usen. Wenn ich die Auswahl hätte Windows
oder Mac, würde ich eindeutig Mac benutzen.
Aber ich kenne niemanden, der zufrieden mit Mac
war und gesagt hat, ich will jetzt Linux verwenden.
Für mich persönlich ist es deutlich
angenehmer.
Ich glaube, wir verstehen es.
Ich glaube, wir verstehen es,
um was es geht.
Auf geht's.
Das ist das Logo von Alma-Linux.
Hätte ich nicht erkannt.
Also Alma-Linux
und Rocky-Linux
sind die beiden,
die das Logo haben.
Das ist das Logo von
Rocky-Linux.
Rocky-Linux und Rocky-Linux
sind ja die neuen CentOS.
Also quasi RedHat-Nachbauten.
Freie RedHat-Nachbauten,
die quasi RedHat-Logos und das Gedöns
entfernt haben.
Leute, seht ihr Rocky-Linux hier?
Das müsste auch irgendwo sein.
Ich kenne das Logo von denen nicht.
Rocky-Linux.
Okay, dieses komische
Häkchen.
Seht ihr das hier irgendwo?
Hinter ihm so.
Ja, gäbe ich ihm recht.
Gäbe ich ihm recht.
Also Desktop juckt mich das nicht.
Aber Best for Business, würde ich auch sagen,
viele Businesses stehen auf RedHat
und viele machen ja den Trick,
was ich eigentlich auch
sehr schlau finde
und wahrscheinlich RedHat nicht mag,
aber ich würde es auch so machen.
Die machen ja den Trick,
dass sie ein paar RedHat-lizenzierte Systeme haben
und der Rest ist CentOS,
ALMA, Rocky
und wenn dieses Systeme irgendein Problem
hat, dann wird versucht,
das Problem auf einem der offiziell lizenzierten Systeme
nachzustellen und dann ein Ticket bei RedHat aufzumachen.
Falls man es braucht.
Die meisten Tickets,
egal ob es Microsoft, RedHat
oder Oracle oder noch schlimmer
SAP, Google, was auch immer
ist, die meisten Tickets sind meistens ziemlich
useless und
da gibt es eine Standard-Response und das bringt nichts.
Aber Best for Business unterschreibe ich,
weil viele Software auch
zertifiziert ist nur für RedHat-kompatible Systeme.
Also für RedHat
beziehungsweise dann auch für RedHat-kompatible.
Offiziell meistens nicht, aber
haben sie meistens keine Probleme damit.
Ich wusste es!
Diese Kategorie gibt es nur,
dass er RedHat reinpacken kann.
Fun fact, CentOS was my very first
Linux distribution. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
warum man CentOS noch verwenden sollte jetzt.
Installing stuff. CentOS Stream
is not CentOS. CentOS Stream
is a bastardized version that RedHat
changed around after they bought them out.
They've recently closed
their source code. A lot of drama there.
I'm not gonna go into it. But that's why
these end up in the devil tier.
And controversially, Fedora
will also end up in here.
Ehrlich? Ich mag Fedora nicht.
Also für mich vollkommen okay, dass er das
da reinsteckt. Ich bin begeistert.
Wir haben schon
sechs Linux-Distributionen,
sechs Linux-Distributionen eingerankt.
Und Fedora,
kann man sich vielleicht drüber streiten, aber bis jetzt
stimme ich tatsächlich komplett zu.
I actually recommended Fedora
this past year. I thought the releases
have gotten so much better. And then I was like, maybe
that CentOS 8 drama... Ich mag
Fedora nicht. Also die kann er ruhig
in evil packen.
Fedora makes it into here,
especially this week with them
proposing opt-out
telemetry.
So Fedora is in the
devil tier. Nothing I'd ever recommend using
anymore. Opt-out telemetry?
Was mit denen los?
Was ist denn mit denen
los immer, alter?
Everything from Red Hat kind of goes into here.
Why we got people mad
from the Red Hat crowd? Let's just upset the
Ubuntu people. Let's just toss
Ubuntu in here. Come on.
Naja, okay, komm.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ich hab auch meine Probleme mit Ubuntu.
Ich find Netplan ist unglaublich
dämlich. Wer hat sich ausgedacht
Netzwerkkonfiguration über YAML?
Wer will Browser nur noch
über Snaps haben? Gerade auf dem Server ist
das übelst doof, falls man
X-Forwarding machen will oder sowas.
Aber insgesamt muss man echt sagen,
die haben auch viel komisches Zeug
gebaut.
Gerade ihre komischen Versuche
mit eigenem Display Manager
und
Composite-Window-Gedöns und sowas.
Die machen viel weird, weird, weird
Champ-Shit. Aber insgesamt
gerade wenn man sich mal anguckt,
also Ubuntu
hat ja schon eine ganze Zeit lang wirklich
pioniert auch Linux auf dem Desktop.
Also ich würde die gar nicht so wirklich
mehr in, ich würde die nicht in Devil
stecken. Ich würde Ubuntu
mittlerweile tatsächlich
in Best for Business
kopieren. Weil
gerade wenn du Cloud-Server betreibst, ist Ubuntu
enorm beliebt.
Und vielleicht auch für Noobs auf dem Desktop.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich würde es nicht mit Devil ein.
Da stimme ich jetzt nicht zu.
Okay, er spielt auch
auf Snaps an.
Okay, ja, Snaps sind dämlich.
Why does that change it to a Snap?
What's up, Ubuntu?
You've just gone from this great
OG, original...
Dieser Müll mit Snaps fuckt
mich auch ab. Aber trotzdem,
ich würde Ubuntu, gerade weil die
Support anbieten und auch im
Azure, generell im Cloud-Umfeld recht beliebt sind,
ich würde tatsächlich das als
noch die bessere Alternative,
wenn man Support haben möchte, zu
Red Hat sehen, ehrlich gesagt. Also Best for Business
würde ich Ubuntu reinpacken.
Ich sehe es jetzt allerdings aber auch aus Desktop und
Server-Sicht. Rein aus Desktop-Sicht
ist eigentlich Ubuntu
fast schon Pointless, wenn man
Mint nehmen kann und sowas. Mittlerweile
was ja auch auf Ubuntu... Wobei,
basiert die noch auf Ubuntu oder auf Debian?
...distribution to
just stay the hell away from it as far
as Desktop goes.
You'll still see Ubuntu unlike Servers.
They do have some kind of business-esque
Server-type thing, but this is
Linux Desktop we're talking about. Nobody
really wants to use Ubuntu anymore and that's why
it makes it in the double tier.
Next we got Alpine Linux.
Ah, das ist das Logo
von Alpine. Endlich nicht erkannt.
Okay, Alpine Linux
ist auch so ein Ding. Alpine Linux
ist gerade aus dem Container-Umfeld
eigentlich kaum noch wegzudenken.
Okay, ich gebe zu, ich bewerte das jetzt ein bisschen
anders als er, aber ist ja auch blöd, wenn ich
bei allem immer nur sage, stimme ich zu. Also aus dem
Container-Umfeld kaum noch wegzudenken, wobei
ich ehrlich sagen muss, mir sind Debian
based Images lieber als
Alpine based Images, weil bei Alpine based Sachen
öfters auch mal was kaputt ist.
Insofern,
ich würde es nicht in Pointless stecken.
Es ist einfach viel zu verbreitet.
Ich würde es vielleicht in Creative & Unique
packen, Alpine.
So mit ihrer Nicht-Lip-C
Geschichte und Minimal-Ansatz.
Vielleicht, vielleicht hier rein.
Definitiv nicht in Supreme,
aber auch nicht in Evil.
In Lightweight oder
Creative & Unique würde ich Alpine
reinpacken. Best for Business,
naja.
Und das ist, glaube ich, OpenRC.
Und es ist einfach so eine
großartige Distribution, um auf Container
zu laden. Du siehst es immer in Containern.
Es nutzt einen APK-Package-Manager.
Super, super leicht.
Und du wirst es in der
Geschäfts-Welt viel machen,
vor allem, wenn du...
Da gebe ich ihm recht, was er sagt,
aber ich würde es trotzdem anders einkopieren.
Wir werden viel von Alpine-Stuff machen.
Also, wirklich cool. Schaut es euch an.
Ich habe ein 10-Minuten-Video über Titus Tech Talk gemacht.
Schaut es euch an. Einfach ein kurzes Installieren.
Was?
Antics? Kenne ich nicht.
Chat, kennt ihr Antics?
Wann kommt Linux Mint?
Weiß ich nicht. Da ist es.
Man sieht es schon.
Wann das kommt? Keine Ahnung.
Was für ein Ding!
Was?
Arco!
Ja.
Pointless.
Haben wir das nicht auch mal ausprobiert, Chat?
Und ich wusste auch nicht,
wofür es gut sein soll?
War das nicht irgendein Arch?
War das nicht irgendein Arch-Linux
mit vorkonfiguriertem Desktop-Kram?
Ja, da würde ich mit Pointless
fast mitgehen. Da sind wahrscheinlich einige stinkig.
Ja, da kann ich...
Ja.
Wobei man ehrlich sagen muss,
offizielles Arch zu installieren
ist super easy geworden,
seit dem Installer.
Bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Hieß das Ding Arch-Linux?
Ja.
Wobei man ehrlich sagen muss,
offizielles Arch zu installieren
ist super easy geworden,
seit dem Installer.
Bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Hieß das Ding Arch-Linux?
Hieß das Ding Arch-Setup oder Arch-Install?
Das ist quasi
Terminal-Installer.
Das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht so ein
Polished-Installer, wie das Ubuntu hat,
aber damit kommen die meisten
halbwegs da. Also Arch installieren
mit dem Installer ist super easy.
Da brauchst du eigentlich keine extra Distro mehr für.
...be in an Arch-Distribution.
It's not to downplay
any of the contributions they make,
and I like to steal stuff from Marco all the time.
It's really kind of cool.
But at the same time,
I don't think the distribution should exist.
Those people, those talented individuals
over there should move on
and probably just re-contribute
to upstream Arch.
Because Arch is
what makes this possible
and you can just take the
customizations they make and put it into Arch
and you better understand it
and you'd be less likely...
Ich hoffe, er packt Suse in Pointless.
...break.
So...
Now that we've said that,
there's a bunch of distributions,
we kinda need to toss them here along with it
with that same explanation.
Manjaro.
What happens with Manjaro?
Ich geb' ich ihm recht mittlerweile.
Ich hab's ne Weile benutzt, ich geb' ihm auch mittlerweile recht.
Wait a second, it has some of the best customization.
Titus, noobs can install Manjaro in Arch.
Same problem, right?
The noob will go to the AUR.
They will download a bunch of crap
and they will break Manjaro.
I know, because I did it.
Man muss ja sagen,
dass die ganzen Arch-Linux-Fans
gar nicht sagen würden,
dass Manjaro ein Arch-Linux ist.
Chat, ist Manjaro ein Arch-Linux
oder nicht?
Darf man sagen,
I use Arch, by the way,
wenn man Manjaro verwendet?
Also ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Manjaro hat zwar Zugriff
auf die Arch-User-Repos,
aber
hat eigene Repos
für die Standard-Software,
die quasi so ein bisschen
zwei Wochen Verzögerung haben
zu den Arch-Repos.
Was eigentlich von der Idee her
nicht verkehrt ist, um zu wissen,
dass es eben etwas stabiler ist.
Aber ich hab' mit Arch auch so gut wie keine Probleme
und zur Not mach' ich von meiner VM einen Snapshot,
wo wir grad' dabei sind.
Ich hab' den Arch installiert.
Aus welchem Grund haben wir da einen Snapshot gemacht?
Egal, ich delete den mal, ich glaub' nicht.
Ach, HA-Proxy haben wir installiert.
Unsinnig.
Brauchen wir keinen Snapshot für, zack.
Alles klar, mal ein bisschen Platz aufräumen.
Also, ihr seht das auch so,
dass man das nicht sagen darf, ne?
Arch, by the way.
The main dev over at Manjaro
is very talented as well.
The problem with it is,
hell, I remember in 2019,
I just did a pacman syu
to upgrade the entire system.
It broke, because I didn't read the patch notes.
Die hatten doch letztens das Problem,
wobei das nicht Manjaro das Problem hatte,
sondern war das Arch,
die mit Krupp, mit Krupp gab's doch ein Problem,
dass da irgendwas nicht richtig generiert wurde
und das System nicht mehr gebootet hat.
Da war doch vor so einem Dreivierteljahr ungefähr was.
It should have been like a syyuc
or some different kind of
upgrade path.
And because I didn't do it
according to that specific patch,
it broke my Manjaro.
That shouldn't happen.
It just shouldn't happen.
Manjaro shouldn't exist.
And if you need that type of level of expertise,
you shouldn't be using Manjaro.
You should just use
the supreme Arch Linux.
So that's where that is.
Now, I think
Arctics is kind of a unique one.
Keine Ahnung, habe ich noch nie verwendet.
I don't want to put it in the point list here,
but I kind of don't.
It's kind of a unique tier,
because it's like Arch,
but it differs in one way
that I was corrected.
Originally I did put it in the point list here,
because I just thought, hey,
it's just another Arch fork.
But it doesn't use Systemd.
So the init system is different
and it starts up really, really fast.
Moment, hatten wir Arctics?
Arctics hatten wir vorhin.
Die verwenden nicht Systemd.
Okay, das könnte für einige Leute ganz nice sein,
die immer noch keinen Bock haben auf Systemd.
Wieso, dass ich der allergrößte Systemd-Fan wäre,
aber ich habe mich mittlerweile dran gewöhnt.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kennt ihr Clear Linux?
Ich habe eine Linux-Distribution von Intel,
aber ich würde sie nie als Desktop verwenden.
Es ist wirklich schnell.
Wenn ihr einen Intel-Chip habt,
dann seht ihr, dass es meistens
eine etwas höhere Leistung hat
als viele andere Linux-Distributions.
Aber es ist seltsam,
weil der Package-Manager Swapd
wirklich schwer zu arbeiten ist.
Swapd.
Man kann nicht wirklich viel bauen.
Das ist nicht das am liebsten.
Wenn man sehr viel mit Flatpak verwendet
und man okay ist, mit dem immutablen Operationssystem,
das nicht so viel verändert wird,
ist es fast unmöglich, Clear Linux zu brechen.
Es ist einzigartig genug.
Ich liebe, wie sie jeden Teil von Systemd
leverieren.
Sie benutzen nicht mal den FS-Tab
für Mounting-Drives.
Sie benutzen Systemd-Auto-Mount.
Sie waren eine der ersten Distributions,
die Systemd-Boot wirklich nutzen.
Ich benutze glaube ich auch Systemd-Boot
in meiner VM.
... wirklich alle Systemd-Services leverieren,
ohne Grub und all diese anderen Packagen.
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Es ist definitiv kein Grub, was ich verwende.
Was ist das?
Ist das Systemd-Boot?
Ja? Okay.
Dann verwende ich auch.
Ich war voll intuitiv.
Innovativ.
Intuitiv ist es in dem Fall sogar auch.
Weil man nicht allzu viel machen muss.
Hallo? Okay.
What the f... Alter, VMware!
Was ist los mit euch?
Irgendwie hat das gerade so ein paar kleine Probleme.
Leckt auch ein bisschen.
Scheint wieder zu gehen.
Next.
So it's unique enough to where I'm like,
you know what, I like what they're doing.
Muss an Systemd liegen, ja.
Clear Linux kind of goes in that creative unique category for me.
Deepin...
Ah, Deepin!
Das ist China-Linux, gell?
Das ist China-Linux.
Da muss ich sagen, ich fand,
wir haben das ja mal ausprobiert on stream,
ich muss ehrlich sagen,
von den nicht so
mainstreamigen Desktop-Dingern,
die wir mal ausprobiert haben,
fand ich Deepin, mal unabhängig davon,
dass es in China-Linux ist,
ich fand das nicht schlecht.
Ich fand das nicht übel.
Das machte tatsächlich einen ziemlich
Runden aus einem
kleinen Gusseindruck.
Alright,
let's keep going with that, it's pointless.
Now, people are like, wait a second,
Deepin's a desktop environment, it's amazing.
Titus, what's wrong
with your head? I'm like, okay.
Don't worry. Deepin
is an amazing desktop environment.
It has some of the best scaling. It's great.
But as a distribution,
it's kind of pointless.
Also meinte er, man soll Deepin am besten auf Arch installieren
und dann ist alles gut.
I'd much rather just install Debian and then toss the Deepin desktop
environment on top of it,
and then I'm not worried about what's going on in the backend
with Deepin.
Same kind of goes with many of these distributions.
KDE Neon.
KDE Neon, das ist die
Live-CD von KDE, oder? Wo man neue
Versionen mit ausprobieren kann.
Glaube ich. Da würde ich nicht
sagen, dass es pointless ist, sondern
für diesen einen Zweck ist es wahrscheinlich
ganz gut.
Love? I know I love KDE.
It's a great desktop environment. Ich nicht.
Ich kann KDE nicht ab.
Silly. Like, what is going on?
Why do they have Apt
and then they have another package manager on top of it?
I get that's your dev environment,
but you really want to distribute that to
a whole bunch of noobs?
No. Stay away from KDE Neon.
Stay away from Deepin. Stay away from Elementary,
honestly, if we're going down this road.
Elementary OS fand ich mal
eine Zeit lang für Noobs ganz nice.
It just doesn't
jive with me.
So, we're gonna grab Elementary
and toss it in here too. There's a lot of
desktop environments that are great.
Ich würd's aber mittlerweile auch da reinschmeißen.
Ich find's auch nicht mehr
sinnig. Aber, also
gerade für Noobs fand ich mal
Elementary wirklich nice. Vielleicht würde
ich's auch noch da oben reinpacken.
Them making a distribution to go along
with the desktop environment doesn't
make any sense to me. Just
go grab a good distro
that's a base. Ist doch so.
Ist doch so. Ist nicht
sogar Elementary, Debian
oder Ubuntu based.
Ja, dann machen die doch das, was er sagt.
Ich find's so messy. Ich find's so messy.
I just don't like that.
Why wouldn't you just use the OG Debian?
I just don't understand it.
Debian's gotten so good over the past couple years
that I just don't see a purpose
to these distributions.
I like the contributions, I like the desktop
environment, but it's
where it kind of falls for me.
In that same realm, we got Endeavor
and Groobit too.
Let's just grab both the R2D2 spins.
Really cool customizations,
same amount of programs,
same problem as Minjaro.
We're gonna kind of leave it there.
Farron OS.
Was? Was?
Moment, das hab ich noch nie gehört.
Wie heißt das?
Sieht aus wie Twitter OS.
We're gonna kind of leave it there.
Farron OS.
Moment, ich weiß noch nicht mal,
wie man das schreibt.
Harren OS?
That's this one.
In a place years back,
when your Debian installer was not very good
and it looked kind of like crap.
It had really good defaults.
Why? Why does it exist?
Same thing.
Gentoo.
Oh, die coolen Leute sagen natürlich Gentoo.
Okay, geh ich mit.
Gentoo's great at building
your own Linux kernel.
Let's say you wanna make
where I would like the world to go with Gentoo.
Ja, also ich gebe ihm recht.
Das passt ganz gut.
Ganz ehrlich, die Zeiten von
ich kompiliere mir meinen Krempel selbst,
wozu? Wozu?
Man hat zwar heute vielleicht die Rechenpower
dazu, aber es macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Wir hatten mal
einen auf der Arbeit,
auf der letzten,
der hat Gentoo benutzt
und er wollte das sicher in der VM installieren.
Der musste dreimal neu installieren,
bis er das VMware-Netzwerk-Kernel-Modul
reinkompiliert hatte.
Is kiosks and links
and let's say that menu
at your favorite restaurant.
Seeing like Windows blue screens of death
when I'm going into like a big high-rise building
and I'm like, why is this using Windows?
Why isn't it just using
like a stripped down version of Linux
that will never break?
That's where Gentoo comes in.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht in der Liste drin.
Create it to do one thing
and do it amazingly
and then it will never change.
It will be really minimal.
Gentoo is amazing for custom versions
where you can de-bloat the Linux kernel,
build it yourself
and then have a couple packages
that are really easy.
Using it as a daily driver
and it's really for try-hards
and people that just have a lot of time on their hands.
So for Gentoo, I just...
So nach dem Motto,
jemand schickt dir per E-Mail-Anhang,
was ja heutzutage noch vorkommt,
ein Word-Dokument,
das du in der Creative Unique-Kategorie
auswählen kannst.
Kali!
einfacher, den Proxy sich
einfach unter Arch zu installieren und
die Android IDE und das da drüber zu machen.
Also,
ich persönlich
habe nicht den großen Anwendungszweck für Kali.
Wenn man
sowas auf dem USB-Stick hat,
weil man was Komplettes
in der Tasche haben möchte,
zum Ausprobieren, dafür ist es bestimmt
gut, deswegen würde ich es wahrscheinlich in
Creative & Unique packen.
Ist für Pentester
ganz gut.
Ja, also stelle ich mir das auch vor.
Also,
insofern, wahrscheinlich würde ich es in Creative & Unique
packen.
Naja, gut, aber wenn du irgendwo bist, wo du
keinen Netzwerkzugang hast und mal ein paar
Packages nachzuinstallieren, ich glaube,
ein Kali Linux auf USB-Stick ist
gar nicht so verkehrt. Das weiß ich, ich würde es
in Creative & Unique packen.
Auf jeden Fall nicht in Pointless.
Da gab es mal Ärger.
Ein Kollege von mir auf der letzten Arbeit
hat sich Kali Linux installiert.
Über den ganz normalen
Proxy, wo man ins Internet rausgegangen ist.
Und auf einmal standen irgendwelche
Security-Leute bei ihm auf dem Platz,
warum er irgendwelche Hacker-Tools runterlädt.
Die haben in ihren Proxy-Logs nur gesehen,
dass der halt bei alter Packages
gezogen hat, sich all die ganzen
Kali-Packages gezogen hat und da sind
halt auch von
Passworts,
Hash-Crack-Dingern,
Proxy,
SSL-Fake-Sachen,
und alles, was ich alles dabei und da standen
die direkt bei ihm, ja, WLAN, Zeug, alles,
standen die bei ihm auf der Matte, sagen sie,
warum er sich die ganzen Hacker-Tools da ziehen würde.
Wie?
Was soll denn der Typ machen, wo wir uns
letztens das Interview von angeguckt haben?
Wir haben uns doch letztens so ein Interview mit einem Hacker angeguckt.
Was macht der denn, wenn es kein Kali-Linux mehr gibt, Mann?
Erinnert ihr euch noch daran?
Das war doch, irgendwie, ich krieg's, ich krieg's gar nicht mehr zusammen.
Das war doch der Typ, der irgendeine,
irgendeine fünf Jahre alte Software von GitHub sich gezogen hat,
da irgendein in Anführungsstrichen Schwachstelle drin entdeckt hat und dann erzählt hat,
er hat irgendwie Highly-Secure-Medizin-Software gehackt oder sowas.
Da muss ich mir echt an den Kopf greifen.
Ja, der, ja, ja eben, deswegen, deswegen würde ich's in Creative und Unique packen,
wenn man einfach was Fertiges braucht, wenn ich ein bisschen was Längerfristiges brauche.
Ja, zum Beispiel, als ich, ähm, diese, das Home Assistant Add-on programmiert hab,
was über die Fiat-API-Sachen abgefragt hat, wo ich mal in der offiziellen App
Netzwerk-Traffic mitschneiden wollte, um zu gucken, was die eigentlich macht.
Das hab ich auch erst unter Kali-Linux probiert,
hab's dann aber ganz normal die Software, die ich dafür brauche, unter, in meinem Arch installiert,
weil ich da halt auch, äh, meine Entwicklungsumgebung und alles zum Programmieren hatte.
Das war für mich einfacher, wenn ich einfach mal kurz und knackig was brauch.
Wie gesagt, ich würd's nicht in Pointless packen, ich hätt's in Creative und Unique gepackt.
And I would emphasize this point just by saying, all the people were upset about Kali Linux,
but truly the, the security researchers that, uh, are really good, a lot of them aren't even using Kali Linux.
A lot of them, you know, they're just like, I'm kinda lazy, I don't wanna customize a version of Debian,
and they'll just install Parrot. Parrot's actually, I think, better than Kali, it's a little more light.
Hab ich doch nie verwendet.
Wait, has a lot of the same toolset, but less of the gimmicks, less of the bloat.
So a lot of security researchers actually end up on Parrot instead of Kali.
So I'm more worried about me saying, Parrot's in the Pointless tier, based on everything I just said.
I'd still put them in the Pointless tier, and that's not good for my own self-preservation, because there's many talent,
talented people that do use these distributions, but honestly...
Was ist denn das? Sieht aus wie das KDE-Logo.
They probably should just use Debian.
So, that's where I kinda put these ones. They do have really good tool sets, but at the end of the day, it's just pretty...
Also sieht aus wie das alte KDE-Logo.
It's all stuff that you could easily add to a...
Ach, Kubuntu ist das! Okay.
Oh, da hatte ich mal einen, der hat voll geschwört auf Kubuntu.
Ihr wisst, ich bin kein KDE-Fan, also...
Supreme Distro.
That's all I'm saying.
Also wenn's nach mir geht, geht KDE, geht das in Pointless.
Next up, let's grab something that isn't in the Pointless tier.
Gibt es mehr Linux-Distributionen oder JavaScript-Frameworks?
Es gibt verdammt vieles von beidem, aber JavaScript-Frameworks gibt's definitiv mehr.
Wahrscheinlich seit der Stream angelaufen ist, vor einer Stunde 40 Minuten, wurden schon fünf neue JavaScript-Frameworks created.
Because I feel like...
I feel like I've gotten down on some distros.
Mindestens.
Some you just want to give to a new user.
And this one's gonna make some people mad.
Probably my most controversial pick out of this entire tier list.
And that's Kubuntu.
And I think it's because it's a weak spot for me.
With Kubuntu, I really love it for new users.
Ich nicht. Ich nicht.
Ich mag KDE nicht.
Für neue Benutzer vielleicht.
Ich meine, ich kann den Pick...
Ich kunns mitでも...
Ich mag KDE einfach nicht.
Also, wenn's nach mir geht, wird es in Pointless wandern.
Ich mag KDE nicht.
Aber das, was ich mag, würde kein Einsteiger je verwenden unter Linux.
Du kannst...
Seriously, Leute.
Setzt dem Einsteiger mal das hier vor.
Der wird sich denken, alter, was will der von mir?
Das ist ein schwarzer Kasten im Fullscreen.
Und...
und wenn ich rechts klicke, passiert nix
und wie starte ich überhaupt Sachen, ich hab keine
Taskleiste, ich kann
oh, ich hab nen Browser, okay
also, das kannst du dem Einsteiger
auf jeden Fall nicht vorsetzen
aber ich
ganz ehrlich
i3 ist das einzige
was ich verwenden kann auf dem Linux Desktop
weil es das einzige ist, was
mich nicht nervt
ich mag Gnome nicht
wobei manche sagen Gnome aussprechen
ich mag KDE nicht
ich mag
äh, LX
Dingsbums nicht
XFCE geht noch irgendwie
wenn es unbedingt sein muss, mag ich aber auch
nicht
ich mag
was haben wir denn noch
Budgie nicht
ähm
ja, Hyperland
kenn ich, das läuft leider in der VM nicht
ich mag eigentlich nix
Sway kann ich nicht benutzen
ich würde tatsächlich sogar Sway benutzen
aber Sway kann ich nicht benutzen
weil Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert
und
sie mal wieder
die alte Nummer fahren, sich gegenseitig
zu blamen, wer jetzt dran schuld ist
also Wayland funktioniert prinzipiell
schon, mit den passenden Settings
aber es ist nicht so einfach
mittlerweile, immerhin
kann man mittlerweile
Wayland in der VM einfach installieren
und Fenster resicen funktioniert danach
was nicht funktioniert ist Screen Refresh
also wenn ich Wayland in der VM installiere
da drin Sway starte
Refresht mein Screen nicht
was im Endeffekt heißt
also wenn das Screen nicht Refresht
ich mein ich kann halt nix machen weil
das Screen Refresht nicht
und das einzige, um den Screen Refresht zu bekommen
muss ich auf
muss ich auf die
ups
muss ich auf
auf die Konsole schalten und zurück auf den Screen Refreshen
zurück auf den Desktop, dann refresht das Screen wieder.
Das ist ein Bug.
Gibt es bei VMware und bei Wayland
gibt es Tickets, aber
beide Seiten sagen, das müssen die anderen fixen.
Und man kann es ja irgendwie fixen,
weil neue
Ubuntus beispielsweise mit Wayland
in der VM auch funktionieren, aber ich habe keinen Bock drauf.
Und mein i3 funktioniert
einfach zu gut, als dass ich es irgendwie ändern will.
Aber das kannst du
keinem vorsetzen,
was ich da habe.
Ich gebe ihm schon recht, ich glaube für Neulinge
ist das gar nicht verkehrt.
Ich persönlich mag nichts auf dem Desktop,
außer i3.
Und ich mag auch an i3 nicht wirklich
i3. Was ich an i3
mag, ist, dass es
nicht da ist.
Ich habe, guck mal,
ich meine, ich habe keinen Desktop.
Ich
habe ein Terminal im Fullscreen
und einen Browser im Fullscreen. Und je nachdem,
was wir dann machen, hier eine IDE im Fullscreen
und noch ein Terminal oder so.
Ihr habt ja gestern so, normalerweise
normalerweise sieht das bei mir
ungefähr so aus.
Zack.
Je nachdem.
Hier vielleicht
noch für die Website zum Test noch ein Chrome.
So ungefähr sieht das
bei mir halt aus.
Und ganz ehrlich,
i3 ist halt
einfach nicht im Weg. i3 macht halt
nichts. i3 geht mir nicht auf den Keks.
Deswegen i3.
Und für
zum Starten,
das ist Rofi.
Da habe ich auch
so ein paar Probleme mit, weil es mich manchmal
nervt am Großen und Ganzen. Funktioniert es ganz gut.
Und das war's.
Aber allein schon, dass du Shortcuts brauchst,
um Sachen zu starten,
blickt ja schon keiner.
Das ist wie zum ersten Mal Wim aufgemacht. Wie komme ich
wieder raus?
Ich mag an i3 am ehesten,
dass es, dass
i3 nicht im Weg ist.
Ich brauche auch keinen Desktop mit Icons
oder sonst was. Nix.
Aber für Einsteiger lasse ich mir's gefallen.
Ist okay.
So gentle for the
Windows User coming over.
You should move past Kubuntu.
But from a KDE perspective.
I think it has some of the best.
Redox OS.
Ist das dieses Rust?
Ist das dieses Rust OS?
Diese Rust Geschichte?
Ja.
Moment. Kann man das
wirklich benutzen? Läuft da
irgendwas drauf, um es
sinnvoll
benutzen zu können überhaupt?
Hat das, hat das
einen Browser?
Ja gut, vielleicht hat das geschafft Firefox dafür
zu
cross-compilen oder so
irgendwie. Okay, ich schreibe
mir das mal auf. Wir können das ausprobieren.
Ich muss ja
Redox OS
besser als
erwartet. Ich bin mir
da nicht sicher. Ich glaube nicht, dass es
wirklich was für, man kann es
täglich benutzen, taugt. Aber ich lasse mich da
gerne eines Besseren belehren.
Okay, weiter.
Defaults.
And you learn some of this stuff.
But it's not just learning this stuff.
A lot of it is learning some of the
tools that, the stuff that comes with the
distribution. And in Kubuntu
kind of a kid gloves approach
to KDE for a new user.
Leute, ich hab Spam, ich hab
sinnlosen Spam gerade gekriegt auf
meiner,
auf meinem
Firmen-Dienst-Handy.
Übelsten, übelsten Scam, Alter.
Willkommen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, woher haben die, woher
haben die überhaupt meine Telefonnummer?
Ich verwende dieses Handy für nichts.
Außer für, ich kann
angerufen werden.
Aber mich haben
da auch schon irgendwelche
Shops aus
Österreich und so drauf angerufen.
Also wahrscheinlich hatte die Telefonnummer
schon mal jemand vor mir.
So, also
ultrasinnlos Spam hab ich bekommen.
Willkommen.
Wir haben festgestellt, dass ihr Werdegang und ihr Lebenslauf von mehreren Online-Personal-Vermittlungsagenturen empfohlen wurde.
Deshalb möchten wir ihnen einen Teilzeit-Job anbieten, den sie in ihrer Freizeit ausüben können.
Unsere Ausgabe ist, unsere Aufgabe ist einfach.
Wir bewerten einfach ihre Lieblingshotels.
Es gibt keine zeitliche Begrenzung.
Sie können die Beurteilung zu Hause durchführen.
Der Tageslohn, der Tag ist, der Tag ist, der Tag ist, der Tag ist, der Tag ist.
Der Tageslohn liegt zwischen 300 und 1000 Euro.
Ja, alles klar.
Alle Löhne werden am selben Tag ausgezahlt.
Wenn sie teilnehmen möchten,
kontaktieren sie uns bitte per WhatsApp.
Ja, alles klar.
Block.
Moment, wie blockt man jetzt hier Leute gescheit?
Äh.
Öh.
Ähm.
Info?
Anrufer blockieren, Kontakt blockieren und, und löschen, äh, delete.
Löschen und melden kann man auch machen.
Spam löschen und melden.
Okay, nice, machen wir das mal.
Alles klar.
Ich würde sagen, ich sollte ins, ins Hotel-Business einsteigen, ja.
Okay, er findet Kubuntu ganz toll, habe ich verstanden.
Jetzt kommt Linux Mint.
Okay, das würde ich, warum ich einen Screenshot gemacht habe,
ähm, ich habe einen Screenshot gemacht,
weil ich am Montag mal gucken will,
ob das nicht irgendein Phishing-Versuch ist
von unseren Security-Leuten.
Die machen auch gerne, die machen, die machen auch manchmal sowas.
Ich wollte mal fragen, ob noch jemand das gekriegt hat.
Linux Mint würde ich persönlich tatsächlich hier oben
auf Amazing Funny New Users packen.
So wie ich den kenne,
packt das wahrscheinlich in Pointless,
weil man anstatt Linux Mint auch einfach Ubuntu oder Debian
verwenden könnte.
Ich, ich würde es Amazing for New Users packen.
Ganz ehrlich, Linux Mint ist das Ding,
was ich jedem ans Herz legen würde, wenn er neu einsteigt.
Amazing for New Users.
I would also put Linux Mint here as well.
Ja, okay, gut, stimme ich zu.
Linux Mint has both a Debian spin and an Ubuntu spin in it,
but it is another really good collection.
Ich check auch nicht, warum Ubuntu in Devil gelandet ist.
Let's set up for a new user to where I'd say,
hey, most new users coming over,
or maybe, maybe I set up something like,
my grandpa or something where I'm like,
hey, new users coming over,
maybe, maybe I set up.
Die größte Augenweide ist Linux Mint jetzt nicht,
aber ich finde, es funktioniert gut
und es kommt einem auch erstaunlich wenig in den Weg.
Also wenn ich nicht happy wäre mit meinem i3-Setup,
würde ich wahrscheinlich Linux Mint fällen.
Something like my grandpa or something where I'm like,
hey, you just need a web browser,
you don't want to get it infected
and you just want it to work.
I'd throw like Linux Mint on there
because it's just,
it's so intuitive,
there's graphic tools for everything,
really good tool built in.
Linux Mint Update Strategie ist für neue Nutzer teilweise fragwürdig.
War die Update Strategie nicht,
installiere dein Betriebssystem neu?
War das nicht die Update Strategie?
Bei Versionswechsel installiere ich mein Betriebssystem neu?
Warum ist Debian Supreme,
die Packages sind immer extrem fallen,
ist für Desktop-User doch kompletter Müll?
Debian ist einfach stabil und funktioniert?
Und du kannst im Zweifelsfall auch Testing nehmen,
ich persönlich würde Debian auf dem Desktop auch nicht verwenden,
sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Ich gehe aber trotzdem mit,
weil aus meiner Sicht ist Debian S-Tier auf Servern
und Art-Schlienungs-S-Tier auf Desktop.
Aber am Ende des Tages ist es wirklich gut für nur einen neuen User.
Nun, für Lubuntu, lightweight-Distro,
kann man benutzen.
Es hat ein gutes Toolset,
also für jemanden, der nicht so familiar ist mit Linux,
der hat so ein Potato-Tier-Kinderspiel,
wo sie einfach brauchen.
Das Problem ist,
soll ich euch mal das Problem an diesen ganzen lightweight-Distributionen sagen?
Das ist schön und gut,
dass die Oberfläche und die Distribution an sich lightweight ist.
Spätestens wenn du in Firefox startest und aktuelle Webseiten browst,
ist es egal, wie lightweight dein Linux und sonst was drumherum ist,
es wird trotzdem abfacklangsam sein.
Du hast vielleicht einen Ticken mehr RAM frei,
weil dein System nicht so viel braucht und sowas,
aber trotzdem,
das wird nicht von unbenutzbar zu super schnell.
...werden, dadurch.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, er steckt Suse in Pointless,
Alter, ich mag Suse überhaupt nicht.
Was?
Was ist das?
Ach, MX-Linux, ja, das ist komplett Pointless.
What? What?
What?
Haben wir das nicht sogar mal ausprobiert
und ich fand's komplett unsinnig?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich bilde mir ein, wir haben das mal ausprobiert,
das war komplett,
das war komplett unsinnig.
Was ist das für ein Thumbnail, Alter?
Die AI hat wieder zugeschlagen.
Hier, MX-Linux haben wir da ausprobiert, ja.
Ich fand's komplett unsinnig, MX.
MX-Linux.
Nein, ich denke gar nix.
Weitergucken.
Warum Fedora, das verstehe ich auch nicht genau.
Also für mich ist es okay, ich mag Fedora auch nicht.
Ja, okay, gut, MX-Linux, geh ich mit,
hab ich auch den Sinn nicht verstanden von.
Was ist das?
Ah, das ist NixOS, ich wollte gerade sagen, NixOS.
Das Logo, hab ich gerade am letzten Drücker noch erkannt.
NixOS ist eindeutig kreativ und unik.
Wir können nicht sagen best for business.
Ich kenne niemanden, der es businessmäßig verwendet,
aber es ist definitiv kreativ und unik.
Ich habe gerade ein Video darüber gemacht.
Es sind reproduzierbare Builds für Linux.
Du kannst alles installieren, es sehr einfach reproduzieren
und es zu 1.000 Computern deployen.
Natürlich best for business.
PC Linux OS ist eine Sache, die ziemlich interessant war.
Weißt du, vor vier oder fünf Jahren war PC Linux OS...
Ah, Pointless, Pointless.
Niemand, der braucht das, der braucht das.
Pointless.
Let's see, you had a webcam that didn't work.
You could use PC Linux OS and it might work,
where Debian might not.
But these days it hasn't seen many updates.
Pointless, bam.
I think several years now.
And I just can't recommend it.
It ends up being the Pointless tier,
because everything it used to do real well,
Debian does now.
So there's no point in it.
Peppermint, same thing. Lightweight.
I would say Peppermint has a little bit better package.
Package selection than Ubuntu.
That's why it makes it in the lightweight realm for me.
I really like it.
Das ist Puppi Linux, das haben wir auch mal.
Ich weiß nicht, für was wir das mal benutzt haben.
Auch wo wir was ultralightweightmäßiges gebraucht haben.
Aber das ist so haarig zu bedienen.
Okay, kommt ja gleich noch.
Pop OS.
Okay.
Auf was basiert Pop OS?
Das haben wir auch ausprobiert.
Ich fand es persönlich auch unsinnig.
Er packt das bestimmt auch in Pointless.
Ich fand's auch unsinnig.
Oh man.
Two years ago, it ended up right here.
It was an amazing distribution.
I've even done a lot of videos and even had like my daughter,
my nine year old daughter at the time install Pop OS.
It was great for new users.
But it is a fork of Ubuntu
using the known desktop environment.
And they really haven't...
Das sieht ziemlich...
Stock-Desktop-Gnome aus.
Das ist ja noch schrecklicher als...
Also ganz ehrlich...
Also ich gebe zu.
Ich mag KDE nicht.
Aber ich bin hin und her gerissen dazwischen.
Was ich weniger mag von den großen Sachen.
Weil ganz ehrlich, Gnome...
Ich gehe nicht d'accord mit der Gnome-Design-Philosophie.
Du hast doch nicht mal Minimieren-Button
du hast doch nicht mal Minimieren-Button
an den Fenstern mittlerweile.
Weil das bloated ist.
Das musst du dir erst um drei Ecken wieder einschalten.
Und bei meinem i3
hab ich auch kein Minimieren-Button.
Aber da minimiere ich auch keine Fenster.
Also ich mag Gnome überhaupt nicht.
Und ich...
Ganz ehrlich wahrscheinlich wäre mir sogar noch KDE lieber.
Ich mag die neuen Gnomes nicht.
Evolvt yet into another tier
oder vielleicht sogar hier mit der kosmischen Werkstatt. Sie gehen von GTK weiter. Sie haben es nicht
noch. Und all das, was sie haben, ist wie ein NVIDIA Spin, das gut ist. Aber für mich ist es
jetzt unnötig. Aber sobald Cosmic herauskommt, wird es mehr einzigartig und es gibt tatsächlich
mehr Sachen, die nicht nur Kopien mit einigen Wechseln sind. Weil, weißt du, hey, Pop! OS,
back in the day, one cool thing it did, where like a Debian didn't, would make it up to here,
was like it did, I think it was like a U-Limit and you could do F-Sync and some other cool things.
But all those settings got kind of pushed back in the upstream Debian.
Und sogar Mac hat einen Button, um Fenster zu minimieren. Genau um mich.
So customizations in Pop! OS, I miss anymore. So right now it's the pointless tier. However,
I know System D has some really talented people over there and they could move out of the
place. So I know System D has some really talented people over there and they could move out of the
pointless tier. Next up is Puppy Linux.
Lightweight.
Lightweight or creative and unique. It's weird. It's a strange distro. It's lightweight.
They make custom, it has a strange package manager of like wolf and bark and these weird commands.
I'm gonna put it in the lightweight tier. It could also go to here,
just because of how it's designed.
Kenne auch niemand, der Puppy Linux wirklich ernsthaft verwendet.
Not something I would use and I probably should use a little more,
so I can give a little bit more, better feedback.
But right now I'm gonna just throw it in the lightweight tier.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Sass OS.
Throw it in lightweight tier.
Slackware!
Okay, doch.
Ich kannte bloß das Slackware-Logo nicht.
Ja, Slackware ist die älteste Linux-Distribution, die es gibt.
Die ist älter als Demian.
Und die geht immer noch.
Die hat, glaube ich, auch keinen Package Manager.
Der Slack...
Doch, der hat einen Package Manager, aber ich glaube, der hat einen Package Manager.
Der Slackware-Package Manager.
Sind unter der Haube nur irgendwelche TAR-Archive, die runtergeleitet werden.
Das ist super minimalistisch teilweise.
Ja, also Slackware ist richtig, richtig oldschool.
Also Slackware ist richtig, richtig oldschool.
Creative & Unique.
Slackware is the original desktop Linux-Distribution, really.
Also ich glaube Slackware ist die älteste noch aktive Linux-Distribution, die es gibt.
It's one of the very first Linux-Distributions.
I wanna say it's the oldest active Linux-Distribution.
Yeah, genau.
It's a little bit rough to work with though.
package manager and in some of the weirdness to to the slackware if you love compiling and building
your own program slackware is cool there's a lot of ogs in slackware i don't want to say anything
bad about it because it is the og distributions it's just not not my cup of tea but i want to
put it there next up is solus which has like a budgie environment so it's like its own unique
desktop environment so they're not really copying much it's not a fork of debian it's not solos
okay habe ich noch nie benutzt of anything really they create their own kernel so solace it's real
niche there's not a lot of guides on solace which makes it hard for new users or even intermediate
users to use it but if you're really familiar with linux and you love the budgie desktop environment
solace actually does a really good job and honestly there's no forks they build all
their stuff so in the end solace is kind of an amazing unique distribution
now
okay please pointless please pointless or evil evil is auch okay well it's in the name
yeah okay er hat nicht unrecht ich mag suse halt einfach nicht trampel danke für den sub
ich mag suse nicht man ja es ist aber ganz ehrlich dann müsste ubuntu auch best for business sein
wenn suse da reinkommt für meinen geschmack ist ist
obuto noch mehr naja gut lassen wir's mal it's it's enterprise linux and it's good for linux
uh it's good for linux using linux with it i think the entire german government used it for several
years and uh yeah it's one of those if you're a business you need support waren das nicht
mit dem komischen terminal settings menü keine ahnung ich mache einen großen bogen ums usern
jedes mal wenn ich damit was zu tun habe kotzt mich an probably one of the ones i'd point to as far as using it for
day-to-day for a normal user open suse is there and it's okay doch realistisch betrachtet müsste
eigentlich red hat bei business stehen weil das ist da womit die ihr kohle waren aber gut es ist
halt letztendlich ist so eine tierliste immer ansichtssache warum fedora böse ist verstehe
ich auch nicht wahrscheinlich weil red hat it has some unique package managers with zipper it has
a really unique like control panel-esque type thing with yast but it's not something i like because it's just a little
too niche but if i was in a business and i needed a sport plan i'd probably choose suse for like
workstation environments tails and tails is cool it's obviously creative unique it's meant to run
off of either a usb das das würde ich das würde ich auch definitiv in creative und unique packen
das ist das so erst was edward snowden sogar empfohlen hat für secret kommunikation
zumindest mal in irgendeinem interview
das ist nice wenn man sie braucht and it loads the entire linux distro into memory and then once
you're done you basically turn your computer off and everything's gone so it's really good for like
a one-off task that maybe you don't want to use whatever happened there i think even some
governments ban tails because they're they're afraid people use it for malicious purposes and
there won't be any way to track what they did uh for me it's like i mean honestly i wish i had
another distribution ich habe ich habe von den drei verbleibungen
distributionen könnt ihr mal sagen wie es bei euch ist absolut keine ahnung welche das sind
habe ich noch nie gesehen welche sind das habt ihr eine ahnung ich kenne ich sagt mir alle drei nicht
void und soren nobara okay eventuell habe ich sogar irgendwas davon schon mal angeguckt
kenne ich sagt mir nichts und was ist das was ist das mit dem vogel ist das nobara okay
tag!
in the creative unique cubes os sorry haben wir ausprobiert okay wenn wir es ausprobieren dann
fand ich es wahrscheinlich auch useless oder snowden's one where if you're interested in
privacy instead of using like a tails i'd use cubes it teaches compartmentalization i did a
couple videos an entire series on cubes that was really kind of amazing check it out if you want
next up void linux this is another creative and unique one
you have a unique on non-system d1 everything's built it's not like a fork of a fork
it's a really cool distribution in void highly recommend checking it out i need to do a deeper
dive on it but it's a very unique distribution and then we have tiny core this one is like
obviously the king of lightweight i think it runs on 20 or 40 megs of memory something just
ridiculously small kannst du noch auf ein 4680er booten tiny core is kind of cool
and then we got two more zorin in nobara zorin is something where i struggle it's either the devil
it's either a new user or it's pointless and those keine ahnung
is
Okay, ja kein Wunder, dass ich mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern kann.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was habe ich denn da... Sekunde.
Was habe ich denn dazu gesagt?
Oder je nachdem, wie man es sieht, ich sag mal leider,
sollen sich...
Okay, keine Ahnung, was ich dazu gesagt habe.
Was ist MonkaS, Leute?
Was ist MonkaS?
Was habe ich übersehen?
Einfach nur MonkaS.
Ach, habe ich gesagt MonkaS?
MonkaS.
Und wenn ich nur sagen würde, dass eine Ein-Auf-Person
vielleicht einen Support-Plan benötigt,
dann wäre Zorin das, worauf ich ihn bewegen würde,
wenn ich nicht der Unterstützung wäre.
Und ich würde sagen, hey, just call them
and you can get some support for it.
I think Zorin would be okay for that.
Me personally, it's pointless.
But I don't want to knock it
because it might be good for new users.
And then I added one more, and that's Nibara.
This is a Fedora Fork.
It's a Fedora Fork made by Glorious Eggroll
that is made for gaming.
Glorious Eggroll knows Linux gaming
better than pretty much anybody.
And if you need just the best
stock defaults and you just want
to game in Linux,
Nibara is where you should be.
So if you're a gamer in Windows and you're like,
I want to try Linux gaming,
Nibara is where you go.
Because everything out of the gate is set.
You don't have to know a whole lot about Linux.
You can just install Nibara and go.
It's really a well done
distribution, even though I give it
kind of a knock these days being based on Fedora.
But to be expected
because Glorious Eggroll, who makes it,
actually works at Red Hat,
so he knows it the best.
And he does some of the best work
out there when it comes to Linux gaming
because almost anybody that does
Linux gaming knows about
Proton GE, which is made by
Glorious Eggroll, which makes Nibara.
And he does all these great
customizations to make
Linux gaming a thing.
So this is
the Linux tier list.
Let me know your hate down in the comments below
because I trashed your distribution.
Sorry, but I want to say
you get my rationale
for each one of these distributions as you've gone through.
This gives you kind of an idea
of why I put things in certain
categories and know that this tier list
could look different for you
and know that...
Also, ohne Mist, ich hätte
das nicht gedacht,
aber ich gehe tatsächlich
bei den meisten Entscheidungen
in dieser Tierlist mit.
Vor allem mal bei den 2S-Tier-Distros.
Just because I don't want people to choose...
Okay, den Rest müssen wir uns nicht mal angucken.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Ja, warum Fedora
der Bad Devil ist, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ich meine, ich habe keine Schmerzen mit, ich mag Fedora nicht.
Ihr habt vielleicht gemerkt, ich mag die meisten Sachen
nicht davon, aber...
Fragt man sich, warum ich eigentlich hauptsächlich
Linux benutze, oder? Mir gef... Ich mag auch nicht, aber...
Ich mag 95% der Distros nicht
und 95% der Desktops-Environment nicht
und eigentlich geht mir das alles auf den Keks,
aber trotzdem benutze ich hauptsächlich Linux.
Muss an was anderem liegen.
300 Tabs auf...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Tabs, Tabs...
Tabs...
Tabs... Ah, hier habe ich erst wieder fast alles
zugemacht. Ich... Das ist... Leute,
jetzt... Ich kann euch sagen,
deswegen benutze ich Linux. Das ist das
Allerwichtigste. Läuft bestimmt auch
in WSL. Wahrscheinlich.
Beste.
Kennst du Plinking Lights?
Nee. Oder noch
besser,
wenn es ein bisschen bunter sein darf.
Achtung, Epilepsie-Warnung.
Ach, das Star Wars in ASCII. Ja, das kenne ich.
Spät.
Ja. Leute, ich kriege
langsam Hunger, aber es ist noch so früh.
Es ist erst 11.47 Uhr, ja.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Zeige ich euch mal her.
Hatten wir denn nicht hier was? Raspberry Pi?
Raspberry Pi?
5K, PS2,
Wii und
Jubantu.
Ja, gucken wir doch mal,
wie gut es jetzt drauf läuft.
Ich meine, so gut wie auf
der X68 Emulator-
Kiste hier, garantiert nicht.
Allein schon durch die GPU.
Aber mal gespannt.
Kennst du was?
GTI. Okay, die
Abkürzung ist auch für vieles benutzt.
Ich weiß...
Ich weiß nicht, was GTI ist und
nicht, was SL ist.
Ach, du meinst...
Du meinst das Terminal-Programm, der Zug, der da
durchfährt, oder was?
Der Zug? Oder...
Habe ich überhaupt...
Habe ich SL installiert? Nee.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
... PS2,
Gamecube und Wii-Spiele.
Außerdem ein vollständiges Ubuntu-Linux.
So richtig mit Animationen
und allem drum und dran.
Ich kann den jetzt per Knopfdruck einschalten.
Oh mein Gott.
Es gibt nämlich zum ersten Mal einen Einschaltknopf.
Ich dreh durch.
Was? Der hat einen Einschaltknopf? Man muss jetzt nicht mal das Kabel rein-
rausreißen die ganze Zeit?
Der Raspberry 5 hat jetzt einen Einschaltknopf.
In diesem Video gucke ich mir mal genauer an,
wie sich der Kleinstrechner Raspberry Pi 5
so in der Praxis schlägt,
ob sich das Ding als Arbeitsplatzrechner eignet
oder als Spielkonsole
und natürlich, was nervt im Moment noch.
Ich habe den Raspberry 5 eine Woche lang
jeden Tag im Einsatz gehabt.
Dutt, dutt, dutt, dutt, dutt, dutt, dutt.
Liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen.
Dieses Intro, Alter.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von S2 Software.
S2 ist ein führendes Unternehmen
im Bereich gebrauchter
Software-Lizenzen von Microsoft
und sucht Reseller.
Das Besondere bei S2, ihr seid rechtlich 100%
auf der sicheren Seite,
denn alle Lizenzen-
Wir hatten ja schon zur Veröffentlichung
des Raspberry Pi 5 ein Video gemacht
in dem wir gesprochen haben,
dass wir uns noch mal tiefer
in den Raspberry Pi 5 reinknien.
Das habe ich auf jeden Fall gemacht
und nicht nur...
Reinknien in sowas ist echt schmerzhaft.
Ich hatte mal so einen Pinheader
in der Ferse stecken.
Das ist nicht ohne.
Das war richtig eklig.
Wisst ihr, dass der,
dass das nicht synchron ist,
wenn es dir in den Fuß sticht
und dass es weh tut?
Wenn es in die Ferse sticht,
habe ich gemerkt,
du hörst das und du merkst das
bevor es weh tut.
Ich hatte wohl irgendwann mal
von so ein paar Jumperkabeln
hier
war es auf der Erde
wohl runtergefallen vom Basteln
und irgendwann habe ich mich mal
mit dem Stuhl so nach vorne gezogen.
Da macht man so die Fersen
auf den Teppich
und zieht sich dann so ein bisschen
nach vorne mit dem Stuhl.
Dann habe ich die Ferse hintergezogen
so auf dem Teppich
und da lag halt dieses Ding
und dann habe ich es auf einmal gehört
von unterm Tisch
hat es auf einmal gemacht so
weil das halt,
da hat man ja ein bisschen dickere Haut
an der Ferse
und ich habe leicht den Kontakt
gemerkt an der Ferse
und ich habe mir dann gedacht
Scheiße, jetzt tut es gleich weh
und das hat dann auch irgendwie
eine halbe Sekunde später weh getan.
Genau, keine gute Idee.
Ja.
Leck, leck.
Hätte ich das mal besser auf Stadia gemacht,
dann hätte ich den Schmerz schon gemerkt
bevor ich reingetreten bin.
Da hätte Negativ Latency wenigstens mal
einen Sinn gehabt.
Bartoszera.
Zu Bartoszera hatten wir schon mal ein Video gemacht.
Das Raspi 5 Bato ist noch Beta
es wird also auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Wochen
oder Monate dauern
bis alles richtig durchoptimiert ist.
Von der auch sehr populären
Emulationsdistri Retropie
gibt es übrigens noch keine Raspi 5 Version.
Die soll aber auch demnächst kommen.
Die Bartoszera Beta
funktioniert erstmal absolut problemlos.
Hat man das Installations-Image auf
Micro SD oder USB-Datenträger
Ja gut, das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues.
bootet der Raspi in Sekundenschnelle hoch.
Also wirklich schnell.
Schicke Boot-Animation.
16-Bit-Systeme problemlos.
Das war aber auch schon mal zu erwarten.
Interessant wird's ab der 3D-Ära.
Also Nintendo 64,
Sega Dreamcast, Playstation 2,
Gamecube. Ja, der Raspi 4
konnte Dreamcast auch schon ganz okay
und auch viele Nintendo 64 Spiele
klappen da schon flüssig.
Aber eben nicht alle.
Das ist beim Raspi 5 jetzt anders.
Hier laufen auch N24-Problemkandidaten
wie GoldenEye und Dreamcast auch.
Das macht der Raspi auf der linken Po-Backe.
Guck mal hier, Crazy Taxi mit 60 FPS
und Raspi 5 so
Aber was auf dem
Raspi 4 definitiv nicht ging,
Playstation 2. Auf dem Raspi 5
aber jetzt schon, also zumindest in Ansätzen.
Richtig spielbar ist das allerdings noch nicht,
aber wie gesagt, die Bartoszera Beta
ist auch noch nicht optimiert.
So sieht zum Beispiel GTA San Andreas
auf dem Raspi 5 zur Zeit aus.
Der hat auch 500 Millisekunden-Lag, wenn er was
in die Ferse kriegt. Besser klappt's jetzt schon
bei Nintendo Gamecube. Da würde ich sagen,
dass da viele Titel definitiv spielbar sind.
Wir haben hier übrigens extra das Bild verdeckt,
weil Nintendo immer gerne mal eine Welle macht,
wenn hier auf YouTube Emulation gezeigt wird.
Ja, kurz vorm Aufnehmen dieses Videos ist mir
aufgefallen, sogar Nintendo Wii
lässt sich einigermaßen gut emulieren.
Also, Emulation definitiv
jetzt schon besser als beim Raspi 4.
Und da wird noch einiges kommen.
Ah ja, was sicherlich viele von euch interessiert,
die Raspberry Pi Foundation empfiehlt
ja einen Lüfter für den Raspi 5.
Und wie verhält sich das nun in der Praxis?
Da hatte ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen Angst vor,
aber am Ende war ich dann sehr positiv überrascht.
Obwohl ich den Raspi immer direkt
neben meiner Tastatur liegen hatte,
habe ich den Lüfter nicht ein einziges Mal gehört.
Also, außer bei Ubuntu, aber...
Ich würde es tatsächlich... Gibt es schon
einen Clear Case
für den 5er?
Easy.
Das ist das erste, was ich probieren würde.
Das ist passiv
gekühlt, aber der benutzt
das komplette Gehäuse als
passiven Kühlkörper.
Und wenn man nicht permanent volle Pulle,
Volllast hat für mehrere Stunden,
reicht das in der Regel.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass es beim Pi 5
auch reichen wird.
Weiß ich nicht. Nicht ausprobiert.
Ich gehe einfach davon aus.
Bei einem Emulator, Gaming Rechner,
der ja schon ziemlich ausgelastet ist,
vielleicht auch für
mehrere Stunden,
wenn man daran spielt,
dann könnte ich mir das doch vorstellen,
dass das...
dass das nicht verkehrt ist.
Da kommen eigentlich Antiviren-Programme hin.
Windows Defender.
Auch beim Spiele-Emulieren habe ich den nicht gehört.
Ich habe zwischendurch immer mal wieder den
Gehäusedeckel abgemacht, um zu gucken, ob der sich überhaupt
dreht. Aber ja, dreht es sich.
Meistens aber halt unhörbar.
Ich würde also auf jeden Fall empfehlen, den Lüfter
für ungefähr 6€ dazu zu kaufen.
Ihr müsst jetzt auch nicht sonderlich Angst haben,
dass ihr euren Chip durchschmort, denn
wenn das Raspi SoC bei hoher Last
80 Grad warm wird, taktet es sich einfach runter.
Dieses sogenannte Throttling
sorgt dafür, dass man den Raspi auch ohne Lüfter
kaputt kriegt. Aber klar, das kostet natürlich
Leistung. Wenn ihr also nicht wollt, dass
euer Rechner runter taktet, dann doch lieber
den Lüfter benutzen. Ganz konkret brachte
der Lüfter bei unseren Messungen im Benchmark
Geekbench bis zu 11%
mehr Leistung. Ja, und wie ist
der Raspi 5 jetzt als Alltags-Render?
Ich muss sagen, dass ich zuerst das offizielle
Standard-Betriebssystem Raspberry Pi
iOS benutzt habe, was früher Raspian
hieß. Ja, okay, das kann man benutzen
für Alltags-Zeug, aber das war ja
beim Raspi 4 auch schon so.
Also klar, Internetseiten bauen sich beim
Raspi viel schneller auf, die
Gesamtsruptizität ist höher, aber
wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, Raspberry Pi
OS läuft zwar stabil und macht, was es
soll, aber es ist auch nicht sonderlich
schön und komfortabel
halt auch nicht. Also zum Beispiel fehlt
die von mir ständig verwendete Snap-In-Funktion,
mit der man Fenster automatisch... Ey, ich finde auch,
es ist auch... Ganz ehrlich, niemand verwendet
das Ding doch wirklich als Desktop, oder?
Wer macht denn sowas?
Pass auf, jetzt gibt's natürlich die Leute, die im Chat sagen
doch, ich verwende das als Desktop.
Aber nicht so als...
Eigentlich, eigentlich
braucht man die Desktop-Oberfläche auch nicht.
Ansonsten ist das eines der größten Vorteile
vom Raspberry Pi, ist eben
das Ökosystem drumherum und die vielen
Tutorials und die vielen Erweiterungen.
Das ist halt auch der Grund, warum
keiner dieser anderen Raspberry Pi-Clones
das irgendwie ersetzen konnte,
auch in Zeiten von Raspberry Pi-Mangel.
... oder in den Viertel
des Bildschirms einrasten lassen kann. Okay, kann
ich mit leben, aber was mich echt richtig
genervt hat, die hässliche Textdarstellung
von meinem Lieblings-E-Mail-Programm, Thunder
Bird und der absolut unübersichtliche
App-Store.
Ja, Font-Rendering unter Linux
ist so ein Ding, wenn man es nicht ordentlich eingestellt
hat. Mittlerweile ist es viel besser geworden.
Du brauchst eigentlich
fast keine Font-Config mehr.
Also, das heißt so.
Das, was unter Linux die Font-Config
macht, heißt Font-Config. Wahnsinnig
sonderlich kreativ, was die Benahmung angeht.
Du brauchst nur die richtigen
Schriftdaten installiert. Und wenn du mehrere
Schriftdaten hast, die Priorität
richtig. Aber ansonsten,
ich meine, muss man mal sagen, kann sich
hier eigentlich nicht beschweren, oder?
Mein Font-Rendering und so ist echt
voll in Ordnung.
Grafische Oberfläche zum Installieren
von Programmen. Nee, also das
ist wirklich nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Und es
fehlen halt auch etliche Programme in den
Paketquellen, also ich konnte vieles gar nicht
installieren. Deshalb habe ich mal
Ubuntu ausprobiert. Das gibt es nämlich auch
nativ für den Raspberry Pi.
Das kann man direkt mit dem Raspberry
Pi Imager installieren, muss man nicht
mal manuell runterladen. Und...
Was für ein Unterschied.
Das ist wirklich die echte Ubuntu
Gnome Desktop Umgebung, also ohne
irgendwelche Kompromisse. So sieht ein moderner
Desktop aus. Alles bewegt sich so schön
wobbelig und hier funktioniert... Moment,
Moment. Wenn sich was wobbelig bewegt,
dann muss es auch Wobbly
Windows sein. Leider unterstützt
kaum was heutzutage noch richtig
gut. Kennt noch einer Wobbly Windows von
Compitz? Compitz Wobbly
Windows, einfach der beste Effekt ever.
Beste, beste. Viele können
das ja heute nicht mehr, aber Wobbly
Windows, Leute. Das wäre
der Grund, warum ich wieder einen nicht
heiligen Window Manager verwenden würde,
weil Wobbly Windows.
Auch das Einrasten von Fenstern, also super.
Außerdem, das Anwendungszentrum ist
viel übersichtlicher als bei
Raspberry Pi OS und hat auch viel mehr
Software zur Auswahl. Ihr müsst allerdings im Hinterkopf
haben, dass wir hier auf armen Architektur
unterwegs sind, nicht auf x64.
Das heißt, dass das Softwareangebot
auf normalen PCs natürlich nochmal
besser ist. Aber was man so im Alltag
braucht, das findet man auch hier.
Leider hat das Raspberry 5 Ubuntu zur Zeit
noch einen fetten Bug. Wenn ihr den Lüfter verwendet,
dreht der unter Ubuntu immer mit vollen
Umdrehungen, was richtig laut ist.
Ja gut, Ubuntu hat dafür
wahrscheinlich einfach nichts zur Steuerung.
Mit diesen Befehlen hier
findet ihr auch in der Beschreibung, könnt ihr den Lüfter
wieder auf die unhörbare Stufe
1 schalten. Ja, also generell
hat mir das richtig Spaß gemacht, den Raspberry
5 mit Ubuntu als Alltagsmaschine
zu verwenden. Ging echt alles
super, also zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Tonaufnahmen,
mein USB-Audio-Interface
wurde problemlos erkannt, Videokonferenzen
mit Teams, auch prima. Das einzige
und das ist natürlich blöd
als YouTuber, YouTube ruckelt
ab den 80p, vor allem bei
...
Lass mich raten, warum YouTube ruckelt.
Könnte es vielleicht das sein,
was ich immer gerne so als Beispiel
bringe, was unter Linux schiefläuft?
Könnte es vielleicht sein, dass der Hardware-Decoder
nicht verwendet wird?
Ich will jetzt nicht wieder damit
anfangen, weil das wusstet ihr euch von mir schon
hunderttausendmal anhören.
Ja, aber Hardware-Video-Decoding
ist echt ein Problem unter Linux.
Du brauchst, ich meine, mittlerweile
geht es halbwegs, bis
es halt nicht geht, wie man hier sieht.
Du brauchst halt echt die richtige Kombination
aus Mesa-Treibern,
Browser-Versionen,
Desktop-Versionen, Grafik-
Treiber-Versionen, Grafikkarte
und dann funktioniert
teilweise auch nur ein Codec und dann hört
mal wieder VP9 auf zu funktionieren
und es ist grottenschlecht.
Der hat
einen Hardware-H264-Decoder,
der Raspberry Pi.
...Videos mit 60 Bildern pro Sekunde.
Beim häufiger gebräuchlichen 30
FPS-Standard geht es so gerade
eben, würde ich sagen. Ein paar Frames werden hier
aber auch noch gedroppt. Das sieht man, wenn man mal mit
rechtsklickt die lustige YouTube-Funktion
Statistik für Interessierte
anklickt. Wichtig, safe
klappt es leider nur mit 720p.
Das ist schade und liegt halt daran,
dass der Raspberry ganz wenige Hardware-
Video-Decoder eingebaut hat.
VP9, das ist der Codec, den YouTube...
Achso, stimmt!
YouTube hat standardmäßig VP9.
Das ist richtig.
Ja gut, das wird er nicht haben.
Man kann aber mit einem Browser-Plugin YouTube
forcen, das
H264 zu verwenden.
Da wäre ich gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
...
wieder nicht, aufgrund der
vorher erwähnten Sachen, dass
da wirklich die
Moment, wirklich hat
er nicht? Raspberry Pi ist
nur Hardware Video Encoder
Wirklich? Okay, was
auch immer anscheinend
Glauben genommen gibt es nur einen Hardware Video Decoder
und das ist H265
Das ist ein
populärer Codec für 4K Videos
Okay, was auch immer
Als Wohnzimmerplayer mit Kodi oder so
verwenden wollt, dann ist das eher nix
Wenn wir keine Probleme haben und wenn der
Raspberry 5 nichts anderes macht als Videos
abzuspielen, dann reicht auch die reine
CPU Leistung für das ruckelfreie
Abspielen mit nicht Hardware
unterstützten Codec, aber halt im Browser
in YouTube, ja da sind halt auch noch
viele andere Dinge zu tun und da kommt der
Raspberry dann an seine Grenzen. Sehr merkwürdig
Komplett ruckelfrei in 1080p60
habe ich YouTube nicht zum Laufen bekommen
also auch nicht mit so Workarounds
wie Embedded YouTube Seite oder
Abspielen in Voll C, aber wie gesagt
als reiner Medienspieler, also ohne
dass da ein Desktop mit Browser und so
noch dazu läuft, funktionieren
die gebräuchlichen Videoformate ruckelfrei
Wichtige Sachen noch, wenn ihr viel auf dem
Desktop machen wollt, dann nutzt als
Systemdatenträger keine MicroSD
Schaut mal hier, das sind meine Messwerte
mit Raspberry Pi OS auf MicroSD
88 MB pro Sekunde
lesen, 32 MB pro
Sekunde schreiben und das hier ist
eine USB-S
360 lesen
schreiben, das ist also ein riesen
Unterschied. Und ja, der Raspberry 5
Dafür hängt dann halt noch was zusätzlich
da rum, ne?
...auf Wunsch auch von USB-Datenträgern.
Noch eleganter ist natürlich eine ins Gehäuse
eingebaute NVMe-SSD, die
unterstützt der Raspberry 5 theoretisch auch,
aber dafür braucht man noch so ein Adapterboard,
das wir bislang noch nicht testen konnten.
Mein Fazit. Bin ich gut, dass sie das jetzt
aber haben. Also, der Raspberry 5 ist ein
super spaßiger Computer, vor allem, wenn
man die klitzekleine Größe und die
Leistungsaufnahme von nur 3 Watt im
Idle und 9 Watt bei Volllast
bedenkt. Aber die große Frage, die ihr
auch immer in den Kommentaren stellt, warum
sollte man sich im Jahr 2023 überhaupt
ein Raspberry 5 kaufen und ...
Wegen dem Ökosystem.
... beziehungsweise keinen gebrauchten Thin-Klein.
Ja, also für Emulator kein Raspberry Pi.
Für Netzwerk-Storage kein Raspberry Pi.
Ja, für irgendwelche Desktop für die
Oma auch kein Raspberry Pi.
Was ich, wofür ich ein Raspberry Pi
kaufen würde, ist, wenn ich irgendwelche
Bastelprojekte hätte.
Oder im Keller irgendwas laufen lassen
will. Ja, dafür ein Raspberry Pi. Auch
wegen dem Ökosystem. Gerade auch, was
Hardware-Erweiterung angeht.
Schließlich kommen zum Platinenpreis von
68 Euro für ein Raspberry 5 mit 4 Gigabyte
RAM auf jeden Fall noch 13 Euro für
ziemlich spezielle Netzteil dazu und bei
den meisten wohl auch noch Gehäuse,
Lüfter, Micro-HDMI-Kabel und System-
Datenträger. Da ist man dann ganz schnell
deutlich über 100 Euro und für den
Preis kriegt man gebrauchten, viel
leistungsfähigeren Thin Client. Ja, und
hinzu kommt noch, wenn ich das hier
aufnehme, gibt es in der gesamten
deutschsprachigen Welt keinen einzigen
Lieferband. So kleine Projekt kannst du auch
in ESP nehmen. Es kommt drauf an, was du
machen willst. Also ich habe zum Beispiel
ein Raspberry Pi im Keller stehen.
Daran ist ein, da ist so ein Ding dran
angeschlossen. So ein Ding dran
angeschlossen.
Leider kann man das irgendwie aus
irgendwelchen Gründen nicht größer
machen, weil es die Seite übelst sagt. Da
ist so ein Board angeschlossen und meine
Kabel abgezweigt von meiner Tür-
Gegensprechanlage, weil ich anhand von
dem Analog-Digitalwandler, wie viel
Spannung da anliegt, erkennen kann, ob
einer geklingelt hat oder nicht.
Das machst du halt mit nichts anderem.
Also du könntest dir das auch im ESP32
basteln. Das würde an der Stelle
funktionieren, aber zusätzlich habe ich
da dran noch USB für die Steuerung von
der Heizung und das machst du nicht im
ESP32. Das ist für mich das optimale
Kombi-Gerät im Keller unten.
Liest die Tür-Gegensprechanlage aus, ob
geklingelt wurde und kann die Heizung
steuern über USB. Wobei die Heizung nicht
direkt USB hat. Die Heizung wird über so
zwei Infrarot-LEDs gesteuert,
wo es das offizielle Kabel vom
Hersteller allerdings nur gibt halt als
USB-Variante. Man könnte mit sehr viel
Mühe sicherlich beides basteln auf
Raspberry Pi, aber ich habe da noch ein
paar mehr Sachen drauf laufen. Ich habe
da zum Beispiel auch die
DNS-Faker für meine Wetterstation
laufen, die ja zur China Cloud
irgendwie connecten will, aber nicht
darf. Deswegen habe ich da was
kleines gebastelt. Haben wir sogar im
Stream gebastelt. Was kleines gebastelt,
was China DNS-Anfragen faket für das
Ding, dass es bootet. Und ich habe drei,
vier Sachen da unten laufen. Also für
mich ist das Ding im Keller wirklich
perfekt für den Anwendungszweck. Das ist
aber glaube ich auch noch ein Raspberry
Pi 3 sogar, der da läuft. Die
Kamera, das ist Wifi, die ist einfach so
da und Strom dran per USB. Da macht der
Raspberry Pi nichts mit. Die EU, was, wie
die EU eigenständig Windows 11 besser
gemacht hat. Ah, sie hat Bing rausgeworfen, okay.
Naja, Windows kann ja, es kann ja
eigentlich fast nur besser werden.
Das ist doch so Cheap-Aid. Euer DasBad.
Brauche ich jetzt eine Informatik-Vorlesung
von eineinhalb Stunden. Alter, diese, die
Empfehlung immer. Okay, das hier geht ja
noch. How rich people buy watches. Genau
das wollte ich heute. Das interessiert mich
brennend. Was verdient ein Koch? Okay,
zeigt mal her. Was, was verdient denn ein
Koch? Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich zu
wenig und es ist ein übelst anstrengender
Job. Koch ist echt anstrengend. Also ich
weiß das aus, um zwei Ecken. Mein Vater
hat Koch gelernt.
Hat aber nicht lange als Koch, äh, also
später eine andere Sache. Aber ich habe
euch ja erzählt, was der für, für Scamsachen
getrieben hat früher. Nicht als Koch.
Danach. Das ist echt anstrengend, Koch.
Knochenjob. Ja. Stichwort Oktopus. Das kann
man ganz schön so sagen, dass man dann so
mit drei Armen da steht oder vier auch
gefühlt. Bist ich zufriedengestellt?
Zum, immer, ich bin immer froh, wenn
Classic im Hintergrund läuft. Die ist
nicht Copyright-Monka-Toss.
... muss noch einiges passieren. Auch geheißtechnisch.
Ja.
Moin! Ich bin Niklas, 27 Jahre jung und äh, ich
arbeite als Koch. Endpunkt. Im 5-Sterne-Hotel
Strandperle. Und zwar genau da. Hallo! Komm rein!
Meine vier Räume und ja, die Küche.
Eigentlich nur ein Durchgang. Was heißt
nur? Für mich reicht es persönlich, weil
kochen tue ich auf der Arbeit sowieso
genug.
Mein Job als Koch ist wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich gut.
Mein Job als Koch ist, würde ich behaupten, sehr stressig.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Weil es mental und körperlich anstrengend ist.
Das ist wirklich anstrengend.
Also du hast sehr viel Stress, du nimmst die Arbeit auch teilweise mit nach Hause.
Natürlich ist es in anderen Jobs wahrscheinlich auch so.
Aber du hast halt immer so dieses, ja, morgen, morgen, morgen und die Feiertage und Menüs planen.
Und ja, das ist sehr viel, was da in die Karten spielt.
Also es ist nicht nur das Kochen tatsächlich.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ist auch ein Job, den ich echt nicht machen wollen würde.
Sei für Briesig, oder?
Oder auch nicht könnte.
Genau das finde ich halt schön.
Oh nein, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Musik.
Hallo.
Moin.
Jetzt heißt es erstmal Arbeitsplatz aufbauen.
Hier haben wir so ein Putzmittel oben.
Ey, der hat von hinten, von hinten dieses Schwitzenhalter-Ding, sieht ein bisschen aus wie aus Uncharted.
Der sieht von hinten auch so aus, nur dass er kein Koch ist.
Das packen wir einfach so an, so einen Scoop da rein.
Vermischen das mit Wasser und dann haben wir cleane Oberflächen.
Genau, da braucht man jetzt keine Gedanken sich machen, ob das vielleicht auf die Hände geht oder ob das halt...
Als erstes eine Cremesuppe Hokkaido, danach zwei Schäulen Müllerin, beide mit Bratkartoffeln,
zweimal tollen Filet Schahörn, auch Bratkartoffeln.
Okay, für mich heißt das so viel wie viermal Bratkartoffeln anstatt Kartoffelsalat und einmal eine Hokkaido-Suppe.
Ich bin verantwortlich für die Gemüsebeilagen, die Sättigungsbeilagen und auch für jegliche Suppen aller Art.
Genau, das ist jetzt für mittags.
Mittags haben wir auch eine Karte und die geht bis, lass mich lügen, 14.30 Uhr.
Also wenn man ehrlich zueinander ist, dann kann man sagen, okay, das raubt einem so ein bisschen die Vorbereitungszeit.
Dann hast du es halt schwer, nebenbei noch die Vorbereitung für heute Abend zu machen.
Vor allem, wenn du dann eventuell noch alleine bist, im schlimmsten Fall.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Mach die Musik aus, Alter.
Okay, was ist das? Realschulabschluss, Ausbildung zur Fachkraft für Lebensmitteltechnik.
Ja, die Sachen haben heute so ultra-advancede Namen, Mann.
Höhere Handelsschule in Fachwirtschaft, Ausbildung zum Koch, okay.
Er hat festgestellt, BWL-Shit hat er keinen Bock drauf.
Kann ich nachvollziehen.
Hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Ihr wisst, ich hab's auch ausprobiert.
BWL-Kram, bleibt mal bloß weg, ey.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Moment.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Macht der Internet-Historian jetzt Videos auf Deutsch?
Ach ne.
Pack mal erst mal ein paar Bracket drauf in die rein.
So.
Ja.
Ich finde das geil, wie der sich das alles merken kann, ey.
Oder, da filtert wahrscheinlich jeder nur das raus, was für ihn relevant ist.
Kein Highspeed-Internet, ich bin gedrosselt.
ist da jemand bei Vodafone vielleicht? Die könnten mal ein bisschen weniger Monka-Toss-Musik machen.
Jetzt können wir uns gerade mal kurz entspannen und schauen, was wir alles für heute Abend gucken,
dass auch alle Herdplatten aus sind. Das Frühstück ist immer mit drin und die Gäste können dann noch
das Halbpensierungsmenü dazu buchen. Das variiert halt immer aus vier unterschiedlichen Kategorien.
Also heute gibt's Salatbuffet, Vitello Tonnato, genau, asiatisches. Ja, aber da bist du doch auch,
der ist doch in acht Stunden nicht fertig, wenn er in der Küche ist, von morgens bis
Mittagsessen und dann abends, der ist doch 15 Stunden in der Küche. Zwiebelrostbraten braucht
man in der Wurst gemessen, geschwenkte Bahnhöhle mit Chimian-Schampion-Rahmen und dazu rassiniertes
Ofen. Tomaten, ja, genau. Deswegen, ich schreibe das jetzt in die Kommentare.
Ja, genau. Deswegen, ich schreibe das jetzt in die Kommentare.
Ich schreibe das jetzt in die Kommentare. Ja, und dann fang ich einfach mal alles auf,
auf einer Liste. Das sind die Sachen, die wir jetzt gleich alle zu tun haben. Wok-Gemüse steht drauf,
das müssen wir produzieren, das ist das zweite Menü. Gemischter Reis, da haben wir noch Wildreis
im Kühlhaus, mein ich, müssen wir noch Reis eventuell dazu kochen. Das dann einmal vermengen,
bisschen Butter dabei, dann in Tembal-Form abfüllen. Glasiertes Wurzelgemüse müssen wir einfach
Gemüse putzen, zurechtschneiden, tonieren heißt das. Und genau, Kartoffelstampf machen,
gegebenenfalls Kartoffeln, kochen, mehlig kochende Kartoffelstampf, Kartoffelchips,
vorwiegend Festkochende nehmen oder Festkochende am besten sogar noch. Bandnudeln, genau. Schauen,
ob welche da sind. Oh, Chat, wo wir gerade beim Essen sind. Ich kriege übelst Hunger. Ratet mal,
was es heute gibt. Ihr kommt nicht drauf. Champignons müssen wir schneiden. Da müssen
wir einen Rahmen machen. Das einmal abwenden, die Champignons rein. Genau, Thymian. Den zupfen wir
ein paar später ab. Nudeln mit Lachs, richtig. Korrekt. Und schmeißen dann in die Soße rein.
Und ja, genau, die Ofentomaten. Alter, BR, hört auf mit Toss-Musik, Mann. Das kann man sich doch
so nicht angucken. Da muss ich immer sinnlos rumlabern, dass Twitch die Musik nicht erkennt.
Mensch, jetzt aufhören. Kein Toss. Die haben keinen Bock. Oh, Whirlpool. Ich würde sagen,
die ist aufgekocht. Also, wenn du alles nacheinander machst,
dann...
Dann kommst du da zeittechnisch, glaube ich, nicht bei rum. Ja, das ist halt, glaube ich, die Kunst,
die es dann auch am Ende des Tages ausmacht, dass man halt viele Sachen gleichzeitig gut macht. So.
Ja. Ich hole jetzt noch Petersilie. Das sieht... Das in der Landschaft vorm Zugucken ist das mega
anstrengend. Die müssen wir noch hacken für den Posten. Und Thymian. Das müssen wir gleich noch
in die Soße reinmachen von dem... Oder von der Thymian-Rahmen-Soße. Und wenn ich den da habe,
dann kümmere ich mich kurz um die Tomaten. Und bis gleich. Feiertage sind für mich eigentlich
gar nichts Besonderes mehr. Also,
das klingt jetzt vielleicht übel, aber man ist es einfach gewohnt. Man ist gewohnt,
an Feiertagen zu arbeiten. Und ich bekomme auch jetzt hier in meiner Position Feiertags-
und Sonntags-Zuschläge. Und deswegen habe ich noch weniger Schmerz, wenn ich, sage ich mal,
Feiertags- oder Sonntags arbeiten muss. Und das sieht jetzt sehr fest aus. Aber wenn wir das später
erhitzen, dann ist es gar nicht mehr so fest. Oh, lecker. Lecker. Wollt ihr probieren? Ich sehe doch schon das Grinsen.
Und?
Ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Riecht's gut?
Chefs-Kiss.
Brotgemüse haben wir. Gemischten Reis haben wir. Glasiertes Wurzelgemüse haben wir. Kartoffelstampf
haben wir. Geschmackte Bandnudeln haben wir da. Thymian-Champion-Rahmen haben wir da. Gratin-Ofen-Tomaten
sind gratiniert oder schon verbrannt. Lass mal schauen. Ne, geht klar. Sehr gut. Können
wir auch rausnehmen. Und ja, dann haben wir alles. Zumindest für HP. A la carte. Schauen
wir mal.
Ich bin gespannt, wie die Sitzverteilung ist. Ob jetzt gleich alle auf einmal kommen, weil
...
Das eben war, glaube ich, schon das Durchschnitt. Ja, ja.
Dann kann ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so frei reden wie jetzt, weil ich mir dann Sachen
mehr merken muss. Ja, Weißwein. Am stressigsten ist es, wenn tatsächlich alle auf einmal
kommen.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Dann wird es gemütlich auf den Herdplatten, weil du, Stichwort Oktopus, dann mit acht Armen
im Posten stehst und sehr viel, ja, parallel machen musst.
Und da muss noch was Gescheites rauskommen, weil ...
WJa, das ist dann irgendwann so dieser Automatismus. Dann macht man ...
Da musst du aber echt wissen, wo alles reinkommt.
Und wenn du jetzt mal
die Auf courant ist. Geminute!
Ja, genau.
Ja.
Gute.
Ja! Oh mein Gott. Ist einer giants Hook! Ja, sehr gut. Zwei, zehn, neun. Schm출 myös.
wissen wo alles steht und ich meine das ist super krass wenn die fertig sind um keine ahnung 22 uhr
da müssen ja noch eine stunde aufräumen dass das morgen wieder das stelle ich mir echt heftig vor
die beiden vier die 1 können beschicken oder das ist schon mal ein essen zurückgegangen sogar noch
gar nicht so lange her um ehrlich zu sein das war jetzt vor einer woche dann waren die gäste
so außer sich weil sie meinten dass wir überhaupt nicht abgeschmeckt gewesen wo ich mir dachte aber
okay habe ich zur kenntnis genommen und ja man nimmt sich natürlich so ein bisschen zu herzen
aber ist ja manche ich könnte mir vorstellen du hast richtig abvergesst da auch die aus prinzip
rum schwenken müssen und die auf den keks gehen einfach nur weil sie denken sie können es jetzt
80 essen hier am abend hat oder 90 oder 100 oder auch mehr und sich dann ein gast beschwert dann
ist die quote glaube ich trotzdem noch weiterhin sehr gut halleluja ja ich muss das kühlhaus
ich habe es vielleicht anbrennen lassen aber nur vielleicht
das sieht so stressig aus schon beim zugucken was ist okay da hat sich einer beim br heute
ausgetobt im herzen ja auf dem papier weiß ich noch nicht also da bin ich ganz ehrlich
weil das ist schon ein knochenjob
und da muss man dann am ende des tages für sich entscheiden ob man das sein leben lang
machen möchte oder nicht und stand jetzt würde ich es machen wenn es mehr kohle gibt stein
meißeln jetzt steht eigentlich nur noch sauber machen an ist ja wenn das geschäft durch ist dann
habe ich doch gar nicht so schlecht geschätzt in der küche dann haben sich alle wieder lieb
und dann quatscht man schnackt man was gibt es neues was hat man erlebt und so was also
quasi so dieser die zweite familie das sieht so anstrengend aus
ja messerset ist wahrscheinlich so was wie beim friseur des scheren set da hat jeder so sein
spezialding ist das auch wieder crispy clean ich verdiene brutto 2700 euro mit sonn- und
feiertagszuschlägen so im durchschnitt 2790 euro und das sind unterm strich dann netto 1930
das ist halt jetzt echt nicht wenn du das wahrscheinlich auch nur mal zwölf
das ist jetzt halt echt netter wahnsinn für so wenn man sich überlegt wie stressig das ist
das ist wenn es mal zwölf rechnen wie viel hat er und feiertagszuschlägen so im durchschnitt 2790
2800 mal zwölf das ist echt und selbst wenn es mal 14 ist es nicht viel euro und das sind unterm strich
also also ich würde ich mache erstens nicht können und bei dem stress nicht wollen aber dann dürfte
es doch wenigstens der verdient viel zu wenig dem sollten etwas heißt sie sollten sie die müssten
sich werden mehr bezahlen werden sie nicht machen weil es wahrscheinlich dann so sich für die wieder
nicht lohnt aber es ist halt echt wenig wird das wie anstrengend das ist 1930 ich bin sehr ehrgeizig
gibt es immer noch einen Schritt weiter.
Bis ich zufriedengestellt bin,
muss noch einiges passieren.
Also auch Gehalts-Technik?
Auch Gehalts-Technik.
Natürlich.
Das ist...
Dafür hätte ich echt keinen Bock.
Auf Trinkgeld würde ich...
Oh ja, ja, geil.
Kommt da ein bisschen was oben drauf.
Man muss keine Steuern drauf bezahlen,
glaube ich zumindest.
Aber trotzdem.
Ich will mich so nicht verlassen,
weil das halt auch immer schwankt.
Freu dich einfach über das, was du kriegst.
Wenn es 70 Euro sind, freu ich mich über 70 Euro.
Wenn es 200 Euro sind, über 200 Euro.
Und wenn es 500 Euro sind,
dann freust du dich über 500 Euro.
Heute lief gut.
Also ich könnte jetzt nichts bemängeln.
Bis auf, dass ich einmal
den Rotkohl anbrennen lassen habe.
War eigentlich alles...
Doch, war alles gut.
Für mich lohnt es sich definitiv.
Ich habe Spaß bei der Arbeit.
Das Team passt.
Der Arbeitsweg ist sehr entspannt.
Ich meine, letztendlich ist es ja gut,
dass es ihm gefällt und Spaß macht.
Das ist auch nicht unwichtig.
Für den Stress dürfte es doch ruhig
ein bisschen mehr sein.
Geld.
Und muss jetzt nicht irgendwie am Hungertuch nagen.
Und das ist das...
Ich meine, er bezahlt nicht viel Miete,
aber trotzdem.
Was für mich zählt.
Doch, ich glaube schon, dass das anspruchsvoll ist.
Ich glaube, was es da anspruchsvoll macht,
ist nicht so sehr
die einzige Sache für sich betrachtet,
sondern die Kombination da drauf.
Die Kombination da draus.
Und du kannst ja ja auch nichts verkehrt machen.
Du kannst nicht sagen, ach, ich installiere mal kurz neu oder so.
Wenn es mehr wäre, würden sich die Leute beschweren,
dass es mehr kostet.
Ja klar, die Leute beschweren sich eh immer.
Ich meine, mir ist schon klar, wie sowas zustande kommt.
Aber da müssen sie sich nicht wünschen,
wenn es beispielsweise weniger Nachwuchs gibt.
Weil das ist gerade in der heutigen Zeit,
wo es ja die letzten paar Jahre auch noch so mega teuer geworden ist
an vielen Stellen.
Alter, die Musik.
Toss, toss, toss.
Aber immerhin.
Guck mal.
Ja, gleich mal in den ETF-Plan stecken.
Er hat halt auch nur wirklich wenig Miete.
Manch anderer bezahlt 1000 plus Miete, je nachdem, wo du bist.
Aber trotzdem, also für den Stress echt nicht ohne.
Sag ich mal danke fürs Zuschauen
und hoffe, dass ich euch heute ein paar charmante Einblicke
in mein Berufsleben.
So, Leben, ich hoffe, ich konnte euch heute ein paar charmante Einblicke...
Aber scheint ein echt netter Kerl zu sein.
Leck mich fett, Junge.
Das ist ja so schrecklich.
So, Leben, ich bedanke mich fürs Zuschauen.
Und hoffe, dass ich euch heute ein paar charmante Einblicke
in mein Berufsfeld geben konnte.
Und hier findet ihr noch die Moneymaker-Doku in der ARD-Mediathek.
Und hier findet ihr noch weitere Folgen zu Lot sich das.
Und die werden nicht verlinkt.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Aber was ein Pfleger in der Notaufnahme verdient,
der verdient wahrscheinlich noch weniger.
Wobei ich gehört habe, dass du als Pfleger, wenn du flexibel bist,
mittlerweile gar nicht schlecht verdienen kannst.
Also mit flexibel ist gemeint, wenn du bei irgendeiner Zeitarbeitsfirma bist
und dort einspringst, wo Leute gebraucht werden.
Dass das echt ganz gut sich bezahlt wird, ja.
Boah, das geht doch klar.
Das kann man sich geben.
Schade, dass das nicht so viele Leute machen können,
wie bei uns in der IT.
Ich sitze gerade hier und streame und habe passives Einkommen, quasi.
Ohne in die Gruppe zu kommen.
Weil ich dieses Wochenende Bereitschaft habe.
Und allein für die Verfügbarkeit, dass ich das Handy hier liegen habe,
kriege ich Geld.
Also insofern, da muss ich nicht in die Telegram-Gruppe für passives Einkommen.
Ich muss einfach da sitzen.
Aber man muss sagen, dieses Wochenende war echt schon ein bisschen stressiger.
Es war gestern was, hat mich einer angerufen.
Und heute Morgen um 6.30 Uhr kam eine SMS.
Das ist richtig, richtig, richtig doof.
Dass irgendein System im Monitoring keine Daten mehr empfangen hat.
So, dann logge ich mich ein, heute Morgen um 6.30 Uhr.
Guck drauf.
System läuft, sieht gut aus.
Ja, SMS.
Und wir werden alarmiert über unterschiedlichste Wege.
So, guck ich rein.
Der Checkmk-Agent ist irgendwie im Arsch.
Okay, nice.
Neu gestartet, immer noch kaputt.
Aber Server geht noch.
Habe ich ins Ticket reingeschrieben.
Was soll ich machen?
Können sich am Montag die Leute, die sich mit dem System auskennen, drum kümmern?
Ne, Ticket war schon auf.
Ich habe ins Ticket was reingeschrieben und bis Montag.
Ne, für mich nicht.
Ich habe Urlaub jetzt.
Ich habe Urlaub bis nächstes Jahr.
Hast du dir das ganze Jahr sonst keinen Urlaub genommen?
Richtig.
Tägliches Streams.
Ne, vor allem, ja, mehr Streams und vor allem mal wieder ordentliche Videos auf YouTube.
Ah ja.
Irgendwo muss das ja hin.
Ich habe jetzt quasi dieses...
Diese Bereitschaft am Wochenende ist echt das letzte, was ich mache dieses Jahr.
Nächste Woche noch zwei Tage habe ich noch ein Teambuilding-Workshop.
Aber letzter Arbeitstag, wo wirklich was gemacht wird, war am Freitag.
Du hast aktuell drei Tage Woche, weil so viel Überstunden.
Exzellent, ja.
Ja, ich bin weg bis Januar.
Ah, du weißt ja, wo du mich findest.
Wie viele Urlaubstage hast du?
24.
Ich arbeite nur 80 Prozent.
Also bekomme ich nicht 30, sondern 24.
Ja, deswegen mache ich das nicht.
Dazu müsst ihr erst mal Videos hochladen.
Meine Einkommen über YouTube und so ist echt nicht die Welt gerade.
Und da ich die letzte Zeit auch recht unregelmäßig gestreamt habe.
Auf Twitch ist aber okay.
Ja, aber da war auch schon mehr.
Aber ich mache das ja nicht, um krass Kohle zu verdienen.
Trotzdem habe ich natürlich nichts gegen frei gewordene Prime-Subs.
Warum machen wir die vor immer aus?
Weil ich habe übelst Hunger.
Dann baller jeden Tag zwei.
Nee, so viel fällt mir doch gar nicht ein, dass ich zwei Tage ein Video raus, zweimal am Tag ein Video rausballern könnte.
So viel.
Keine Ahnung.
Nudeln mit Lachs könnte ich zweimal am Tag rausballern.
Ja.
Ich esse jetzt aber Nudeln.
Reactions.
Oh nee, Alter.
Ich finde die meisten Reactions sind so useless.
Also, wenn überhaupt, dann muss es halt auch irgendwas sein, wo ich ein bisschen was dazu sagen kann zusätzlich.
Ja, zum Beispiel das Reacten auf irgendwie eine Linux-Tierlist oder so.
Aber da brauche ich den Tyler, der das zusammenschneidet.
Weil wenn ich ein 27 Minuten Video gucke, labere ich eine Stunde.
Das ist zu lang.
Kochvideo, Quatsch, Blödsinn.
Juckt doch keinen.
Wahrscheinlich würde das sogar Leute gucken.
Das ist ja das Schlimme an Reaction-Videos.
Die schlechtesten und langweiligsten Reaction-Videos werden trotzdem massig geguckt.
Verstehe ich gar nicht.
Aber nee, das ist mir zu doof.
Na klar.
Immer.
Weißt du.
So geplante Sachen machen bin ich ja das beste Beispiel für.
Ich setze ja immer geplante Sachen zeitnah um.
Wie man auch die letzten Jahre über gesehen hat.
Wie ist das eigentlich bei Teilzeit?
Ist es da wichtiger zu schauen, dass man einen Tag nimmt, der weniger Feiertage im Jahr hat?
Ja und nee.
Also ich am Montag.
Montag ist glaube ich mit der schlechteste Tag, den man haben kann, was Feiertage angeht.
Weil sehr viele Tage auf Montag, also Feiertage, standardmäßig auf Montag fallen.
Trotzdem finde ich persönlich Montag am sinnigsten.
Weil montags sind sie alle noch super motiviert aus dem Wochenende.
Und es passiert total viel.
Montag ist immer stressig.
Und für das, was ich am Montag machen will.
Ja auch mal mich, war zumindest der ursprüngliche Plan.
Auch mal mit ein paar Sponsoring Leuten für YouTube unterhalten.
Die haben montags auch noch richtig Bock.
Also Montag ist für das private Business der beste Tag was zu machen.
Und der stressigste Tag auf der Arbeit.
Deswegen habe ich Montag genommen.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man das auch komplett kleidzeitmäßig machen.
Und halt dann nehmen wann man will.
Aber ich habe Montag fest.
Was ich ganz gut finde.
Da wissen alle, montags bin ich nicht da.
War bei der alten Arbeit so.
War bei der Arbeit davor so.
Und bis bei dieser Arbeitsstelle.
Also bei dem Job genauso.
Montags.
Kann man eine Ausbildung noch später beginnen?
Ja.
Das hängt davon ab, ob du einen Betrieb findest, der dich nimmt.
Ich glaube, du kannst theoretisch sogar irgendwann Anfang des Jahres oder so noch einsteigen.
Dann hast du gerade in der Berufsschule ein bisschen was verpasst.
Aber Berufsschule ist eh komplett useless.
Wichtig ist halt, dass du einen Ausbildungsbetrieb findest.
Der Leute sucht ja.
Die meisten suchen halt.
Die haben schon gesucht.
Bei den meisten fängt man halt zum 1.9. oder zum 1.8. und zum 1.10.
Meistens zum 1.9. an.
Ja, dann.
Ich brauche mehr Views.
Die letzten Videos liefen echt gut.
Okay, das allerletzte nicht so.
Aber das dachte ich mir schon.
Das war ja übelst random Video.
Aber ich.
Also eins muss man ja echt mal sagen.
Ich habe wirklich.
Also mir geht es da wirklich nicht schlecht auf YouTube.
Die Videos haben, wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie lange ich schon auf YouTube bin.
Wie.
Was für Sachen ich früher gemacht habe.
Was ich jetzt mache.
Ich habe enorm viele Videos, die teilweise 50k, 80k und sowas knacken.
Fast 70, 50, 80.
Und das ist echt.
Also das ist definitiv nicht Standard.
Vor allem bei meinem Upload Pensum.
Ja.
Also ich finde, es läuft echt nicht schlecht.
Views.
Was denn sonst?
Ja.
Welches Video ist das mit den weißen Views?
Naja, das kennt ihr alle.
Das ist dieses sinnlose Video, wo ich durch den Schnee laufe in meinem Garten.
Warum auch immer.
Das hat über zwei Millionen Views.
Guck mal.
Beliebt.
Zwei Millionen.
Das zeigt überhaupt nicht mehr die richtige.
Den richtigen View Count.
Ah ja.
Zwo Komma.
Zwo.
Zwo Komma eins Millionen Aufrufe.
Es ist so sinnlos, Alter.
Nur YouTube.
Nur YouTube versteht, warum dieses Video durch den Algorithmus so gepusht wurde.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe auch keine Ahnung.
Es gab doch schon V2 und so.
Ich bin schon ein paar Mal durch den Wald gelaufen oder so ins Schnee.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das so gut angekommen ist.
Ja, ich habe ein paar Videos, was auch über 100k hat.
Also es schwankt natürlich mit dem Thema.
Was ich gut finde, ist, dass...
Äh.
Auch...
Es ist ja gar nicht mehr so viel Gaming Content, weil ich eben nicht mehr selbst aktuell so
viele Spiele habe, auf die ich Bock habe.
Und insgesamt muss man echt sagen, auch der nicht Gaming Content wird erstaunlich viel
geguckt.
Was ich nice finde, was mich jetzt bestärkt dazu, noch ein bisschen mehr in der Richtung
zu machen.
Das Emulator Video 80k.
Dass ich...
Dass ich Windows Notebook auf der Arbeit habe.
50k.
Die Physie Ausbildung.
Das war tatsächlich ein Reaction Video.
Auf ähm...
Technikeller.
Teilzeit Video.
Leichter Clickbait Titel, gebe ich zu.
Aber es ging ja im Prinzip trotzdem da drum.
Ja.
Na gut.
Ok Leute.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Drei Stunden.
Vielleicht, vielleicht machen wir nachher noch ein bisschen weiter mit der Streaming
Anwendung.
Wir müssen ja die ganzen Krustentiere erfreuen, die jetzt neu reingefollowt haben.
Nudel mit Lachs.
Jawoll.
Oder vielleicht auch was anderes.
Vielleicht machen wir noch was anderes.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, wie es heute Mittag läuft.
Ob ich da...
Ob ich Bock drauf habe, noch online zu kommen oder nicht.
Gucken wir mal.
Alles klar Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.